when you begin to create from the field
instead of from matter the only way you
can do that is you have to learn how to
take all of your attention off your body
and become a nobody take all of your
attention off all the people in your
life that you give so much of your
attention and energy to because you have
an emotion associated with them and get
beyond all the people in your life and
go from someone to a no one now if
you've worked your whole life being a
someone or if you've been working your
whole life thinking that you're your
body you're gonna have to work a little
harder because that's your identity
that's what you're associated with and
if this was easy everybody would be
doing it so then you have to go get
beyond all the things in your life your
cell phone your computer your car and
literally go from something to nothing
if I take all your attention off the
place you work the place you live the
place you need to be the place you're
sitting and go from somewhere to Nowhere
you got to stop thinking about the
predictable future and the familiar past
and go right into the present moment and
go from some time to no time and if you
do that properly you become pure
Consciousness that's how you enter the
field now we've done the research on
this we call it getting beyond the self
once you are pure consciousness Europe
taking all of your attention off this
three-dimensional reality now where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I make these videos because of my first
business I quit I'm a business partner I
struggled to keep going I was making 300
bucks a month and felt like a complete
failure and the thing that saved me that
pulled me up was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs I got the
motivation from them I also got the
strategies of what to do next so that I
can go off and achieve my dreams and
quite honestly I still need the stories
today myself to continue my motivation
to take it to the next level so today
let's get some incredible motivation
from the one and only Joe dispenza enjoy
so if you've taken all of your attention
off of everything material there's only
one place you're going to wind up and
that is the immaterial realm called the
quantum field an invisible field of
energy that unifies and connects
everything material
so now when you're creating from the
field and you combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
connected and you feel connected
the suggestion of an alternative way to
create is that when there's a
vibrational match between your energy
and some future reality
you actually no longer have to go
anywhere to get it you're actually the
vortex and you will collapse space and
time and draw the experience to you now
that to me is a lot more fun because the
experience is the unknown you can't
predict when it's going to happen or how
it's going to happen because if you can
predict it it's known so then you have
to lay down the very thing
you use your whole life to get what you
want
for something greater to occur now that
goes against
Generations Untold of conditioning and a
lifetime of habituation believing that
we're we're trapped in this material
world and yet I can I can say to you
without a doubt
that once you understand that formula
and once you know how to create that
kind of brain and heart coherence
the side effect of that
is a change in biology
neurologically chemically hormonally
genetically we've measured it we've seen
Gene regulation changes in four days
more brain coherence more hard coherence
your brain's working better your heart
is you're trusting your heart it's open
there's different chemicals that are
released oxytocin suppresses survival
centers resets the Baseline of a
person's trauma or shock
your immune system goes up
you you lengthen your telomeres we've
measured that too so you're changing the
future of your body you're extending
your life
that's evidence right so we we have the
evidence the know that it could happen
because we've measured it but the real
evidence
is watching the testimonial of someone
who says I had stage four cancer I was
told as a 41 year old woman that I
wouldn't live for more than two months
and I have no
evidence of cancer in my body at all or
someone that's a physician who has
Parkinson's disease that's tried
everything from the medical route and
has one transcendental moment and their
Tremors and their pain are gone then now
they're chewing food they're swallowing
uh they're blowing their nose they're
standing up on their own uh that's
energy affecting matter so we have
hundreds and hundreds of testimonials of
people that not only heal their body but
created pretty profoundly magical things
in their life
so you have evidence in the scientific
world you have evidence in the Practical
world and evidence
is the loudest voice right now the brain
is a record of the past it's an artifact
of everything we've learned and
experienced to this moment so most
people wake up in the morning and they
think about their problems and their
problems or memories that are etched in
their brain that are connected to
certain people and certain problems at
certain times in certain places and the
moment they start thinking of their
problems they're thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
or the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so many
people reaffirm their state of being
completely by the past and so it only
takes a thought and a feeling an image
and emotion a stimulus in response to
start the conditioning process so we
start to condition the brain and body
hardwire the brain condition the body
emotionally into the past the problem is
the body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating the
emotion and the emotion we're creating
by memory alone the body's believing us
living in the same past environment 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year so
and the person gets up and then they run
through the same routine as they always
do and uh in time their body moves into
a state of autopilot now their body is a
set of programs a habit that's dragging
them into the same future based on what
they did in the past and so to change
them also requires being greater than
the emotions that have been conditioned
into the body and the habituations that
have been conditioned into the body in
the predictable future so we have to
understand then that change requires not
only being created in the environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change them to be creative in the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
or wants to get up and do things they
think they can't meditate but in fact if
they can settle their body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger to that frustration
to the fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone or doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and say I
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions our environment be greater
than our body as the mind and and to be
greater than time
that all of a sudden causes the person
to start believing in themselves a
little bit more and that's when um
possibility starts to unfold when a
person begins to slow their brain waves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
Focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we narrow our focus on
the cause and it causes each one of
these different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers
where we reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta State and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow Focus to a broad
focus when you open your focus when you
open your awareness that's what creates
coherence in the brain because you're
going against that habit
putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent Focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
Divergent Focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to Alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain right into the home
of the autonomic nervous system okay the
person can't change their brain waves
it'll never work because they're in
their neocortex in their thinking mind
right so that's one thing that has to
happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a Divergent
Focus now by the convergent you're
focusing on let's say I'm going to focus
on this energy center right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your your sexual organs you move to
your second Center you put your
attention there that's your where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so now you're beginning to
Direct Energy yeah into that Center but
now you become aware of the space around
it why to create coherence and that
little brain send the coherent message
to the cells and tissues go to your
third center right in the pit of your
gut well there's a huge Celiac plexus
there a solar plexus a lot of
connections in there so now put your big
one that's a big always getting a lot of
signs there yeah here and here art and
solar plexus yeah that's those are big
ones and you tune into that energy then
you put your attention in your heart it
has its own individual brain yeah and
when you make energy here when energy
finally arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've measured
it so now once you start opening your
heart you got more energy in your heart
you get more energy in your brain got it
start on time just go straight to the
heart that's why we do it that's exactly
why we that's why we open the heart so
it creates a field and it begins to
drive energy of the brain so now that
energy is going to cause the person
to have a different Consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can Master convergent and Divergent
Focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
Expressions most people number one they
get up in the morning and the first
thing they do is they think about the
problems in their life and those
problems are memories from the past so
the moment they think about their
problems they're thinking in the past
right every one of those problems has an
emotion attached to them so they start
feeling unhappy or unworthy or whatever
and how you think and how you feel is
your state of being so most people's
entire state of being is in the past
when they start today so often The
Familiar past they're going to live in a
predictable future right so they get up
and they check their cell phone they
check their text their WhatsApp their
Facebook they post something on Facebook
they tweet they Twitter they check the
news then they go to the bathroom get a
cup of coffee take a shower get dressed
check more emails drive to work the same
way do the same thing so different
program they've actually lost their free
will to the program wow so if you start
your day and you start your day with
this simple question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that I can be today you ask yourself
that question now listen your body's
going to go like well you got to get a
cup of coffee and you gotta get tired
I'm tired and you gotta go ah
body
uh you're not the mind I'm the mind
right now you're gonna sit here I'm
gonna feed you uh you're gonna get your
coffee you're gonna do all those things
but right now this is my time you're
gonna obey me right so now the body's no
longer the mind you're the mind and so
when it wants to get up and you become
aware of it and we turn back to the
present moment every time you do that's
a victory and you're changing some
aspect of yourself so then
ask yourself I do this all the time
write down four thoughts that you're
going to stay conscious of the whole day
I can't it's too hard you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day you know for
weeks on end write down what you speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act
how do you how do you act do you
complain do you blame you make excuses
you feel sorry for yourself that's a
victim Consciousness what emotions do
you live by is it possible that you're
so used to living by guilty you don't
even know it's guilt it just feels like
you do you allow your energy to drop
become conscious of those states of mind
and body and review them and say this is
the old self then say
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and start firing and wiring
and start feeling it what behaviors will
I demonstrate today what choices will I
make one day one Lifetime and just like
you did rehearse them rehearse the whole
entire thing begin to install the
neurological Hardware in your brain and
if you keep installing it the hardware
is going to become a software program
you're going to start thinking and
acting that way and then here's the
tough part
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest and don't get
up until you feel that way also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I think the first thing is to
learn every time you learn you make new
Connections in your brain and learning
is making those connections and I was
joking with my staff this week I said
nobody reads anymore nobody reads nobody
reads anything learn information why
because we found out
that in our events if you can be present
and not look at your cell phone or not
talk about your past but be present with
the content and I can combine quantum
physics with Neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology Mind Body
Connection epigenetics electromagnetism
you can really get it like you can give
me the nod and then I say okay you I
look at an audience of 1500 600 people
okay well turn to the person next to you
and teach it back to them if you can't
explain that um
it's not wired in your brain and you'll
doubt that it's possible and you'll do
something differently okay if you can
explain it then you're causing your
brain to Fire and new sequences and new
patterns and new combinations whenever
you make your brain work differently
you're changing your mind why
his mind is the brain in action so you
keep reminding yourself in this now this
it's easier to forget this than remember
it you know it takes practice it really
you can't get it in one bite it's a
learning process right so now you're
installing the neurological Hardware in
your brain in preparation for the
experience so knowledge is the precursor
to the experience right without the
knowledge and the information it's
conjecturous right so the more you
understand the what in the terms of what
you're doing and the why you're doing it
the application the Practical aspect the
how becomes exciting like oh I'm going
to get it as an example you can take
someone and throw them in an ice bath
we have no knowledge of ice but what
that can do and then because they have
no knowledge the ice path is actually
gonna is going to cost them harm right
right you take that person you can teach
them a few things and put them in an ice
bath and actually be instrumental
actually getting value from it well the
prefrontal cortex the one that said now
you got to make this you got to make
this valuable you can take a person
and you can you can put them in an
environment and they can perceive the
environment as a problem and you can
measure their autonomic response and
it'll weaken their autonomic response
you can take that person and have them
perceive it as a challenge and it'll
actually strengthen their autonomic
response okay so now what's the what's
what's the reason behind this well you
gotta you gotta put as much tension on
your inner world
of how you're thinking and how you're
feeling and how you're going to behave
as much as your outer world of
three-dimensional reality and meditation
is just a way to say okay let me get my
brain and body right I'm gonna present
Ed mylett to the world today I got one
lifetime one groundhog day one day
I just want something different
something unusual something mystical
some sign from the universe that I
created and I wanted to come in a way
that I would never think of that would
be the unknown because if I can predict
it it's the known okay let me before I
get up and grab my phone
and do all my things and get plugged
back into my Known World let me just say
okay who do I no longer want to be I
want to become so conscious that I won't
go unconscious again the fundamental
question is how many times
am I going to forget until I stop
forgetting and start remembering that is
the moment there's nothing mystical
about this
this is the work
and then you're gonna say okay who do I
want to be when I open my eyes okay let
me think about this how would greatness
left we I don't know read a book on
greatness read a book on Nelson Mandela
you want to be wealthy read about
wealthy people and you're going to see
that they didn't just make their wealth
they lost a ton of money and failed them
a million times it was and that's
reality okay well let's what what were
the qualities they were they had
perseverance they had determination they
let they cut their losses they forgave
they forgot about it they went on okay
so how am I going to behave let me
rehearse how I'm going to behave
and I'm going to do me take my time I
have I have plenty of time to do let me
just behave let me think about how I'm
going to behave differently in this
situation how am I going to change my
emotional response when did I fall from
grace yesterday and went back to my old
self let me just I'll set up I'll set an
alarm on my phone every three hours I'm
gonna just gonna go off and I'm gonna
take a moment and get back into the
feelings of my future okay
if I can do that over and over again
well what what do you think could happen
in my life as a result of it so
knowledge being the Forerunner the
application simple stuff simple stuff
practice hard coherence there's plenty
of stuff that we can you know we can
talk about practice brain coherence it's
we know we know I asked the brain
scientists what percentage of people at
the end of a week-long event uh what
percentage of people will have their
brains changed for the better they said
100 100 one week fully immersed in into
the experience you practice it every day
now
he can't do it once or twice and say why
isn't my bank account full you know what
I'm going to tell you you're not that
good yeah that's the only reason why if
you were that good it would happen
you're not that good so show up again
and show up again and keep showing up
and I just was talking to a staff member
today the universe only gives us what we
think we're worthy of receiving right so
then people who show up for themselves
every day I believe they're worthy they
they start feeling pretty damn worthy
like hey they're like I'm worthy for
this not like an entitlement way like
something or are they just like I'm I'm
really I'm real I feel like it's gonna
happen I'm worthy for it I learned a lot
about expectation when I was studying uh
the placebo uh you know it's amazing how
you can give someone a sugar pill or a
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment and a certain
percentage of those people will accept
believe and surrender to the thought
that it's actually the truth without
analyzing it that they're getting an
actual real substance and their body
begins to manufacture the very Pharmacy
of chemicals that causes them to heal by
thought alone so the question is is it
the you know inert exogenous substance
that's doing the healing or is it the
body's innate capacity to heal so so
everybody has been conditioned to a
certain degree
whether we like it or not to rely on
something outside of us
to change our inner State and and and so
when a person's given a pill and it's
and it's blue on one side and red on the
other and they take it and they notice a
change in their internal State my pain
has gone away uh I'm sleeping better
whatever it is
and when they notice that change in
their internal State they pay attention
to what caused it and they start to
associate and condition so well if you
keep doing that over and over again
uh that pill uh becomes a symbol of them
to change their physiology so if you
take that pill and you replace it with
something that's a nerd and they see
that pill based on conditioning when
they take that pill conditioning based
on the past they begin to expect
that outcome to happen again and the
expectation of the outcome is simply
marrying a a a possibility an intention
a vision of a future outcome a new
possibility in the quantum field
and if the doctor's enthusiastic and you
name the substance something that you
can't pronounce and you charge a lot of
money for it and you use a name that
rhymes with something that could
actually you could associate as a as a
known uh you know Niagara and Viagra
there's a strong correlation it's a lot
of flow and and so people are
conditioned to expect an outcome so
when they start to expect the outcome
the marrying of that clear intention if
the person is optimistic if the person
is enthusiastic if the person is uh uh
grateful uh for the outcome a
combination of that clear intention
combined with the elevated emotion
begins to change the body's physiology
for them to manufacture their own
Pharmacy of antidepressants their own
Pharmacy of morphines or pain relievers
their own Pharmacy of dopamine by
thought alone so the question is do you
need the exogenous substance to change
your state of being or can you change
your state of being by thought alone
and by the same means if you give a
person a prognosis and you tell them
that in the chemotherapy treatments you
are going to get really nauseous and
sick they've done research on this fifty
percent of the people on their Drive
to the chemotherapy treatment start to
get nauseous in anticipation of the
event taking place so the question is
can 50 of the people get well on their
drive to work or they're on their drive
to their doctor in anticipation in
anticipation of getting the right
treatment in your studies with the power
of aid
if the person can assign meaning
to the value of what they're doing and
they can see oh my God energy can
actually inform matter okay that sounds
like something that makes sense give me
the quantum understanding
and you get a collective group of people
and we're discovering that Collective
networks of Observers
determine reality and you can get them
in a very specific State and the person
who's receiving the healing understands
the the value of what's taking place
the expectation of what's about to
happen if they're in a state of
gratitude it's kind of an interesting
thing gratitude when we receive
something when we've just received
something favorable when something's
happening to us that we really enjoy or
something just happened to us that
surprises us we feel gratitude so the
emotional signature of gratitude is
something's happening to us or something
favorable just happened to it it is the
ultimate state that we receive in
so if the person's in that state of
gratitude then it makes sense then
they're more susceptible to information
because we accept believe and surrender
to information equal to our emotional
state so that can actually program the
autonomic nervous system to begin to
physiologically change and that's
exactly what Pavlov did with the
salivating dogs just ring the bell and
feed them a meal and after a while the
anticipation
of the event actually causes them to
change their body's physiology their
autonomic nervous system begins to
change as if they're actually in the
process of eating the meal the
anticipation is preparing for the event
ahead of time and we can use that to so
many degrees in our favor would you say
it's smart to focus on one goal I mean
if you're sick obviously it's it's smart
to focus on getting healthy but if you
have a regular life and you say you know
I would like to have the classical stuff
more money more wealth more love more
joy would you say in those meditations
it's smart to focus on different goals
or should it rather be the Big Goal like
a big Vision I have for my life that all
the steps on the way are just
marks I will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick some people come
because they want more money some people
want more a new job a new opportunity a
new career a new relationship some
people want the mystical the people come
for all kinds of reasons to me I don't
care
what I care about is that they latch on
to a vision
and they learn how to create whatever
drives them to that elegant moment where
they're so present and so passionate
about what they want and they have a
clear intention a Clear Vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy into the field and
whatever we broadcast into the field
is our experiment with Destiny
so I want people
to know the how because we have plenty
of people that have made millions and
millions of dollars that were living in
the back seat of their car or filed
bankruptcy we have plenty of people that
were stage four cancers serious health
conditions that are healed but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness that's why we
come that when we feel so whole and so
happy with ourselves so connected to
something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
I want people
to reach that point where
they feel so whole
that they no longer want and that's when
the magic happens teaching them that
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses they open
their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
you're not separate from the energy of
your future you're connected from it to
it but the moment you get in traffic and
you start getting angry you get on the
line at the bank and you start getting
impatient or you're sitting in a staff
meeting you start judging A co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
Future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person made
me feel this way and think this way I'd
say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
I think and feel
but a person who's producing outcomes in
their life all of a sudden they say wow
the way I'm thinking and feeling is
creating outcomes in my life
now I'm a creator of my life and now I
believe less I'm a victim of my life I
want to show you what it looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections if you took a
hundred thou hundred billion sheets of
paper and you stack them on top of each
other it would be 5 000 Miles High
that's the distance from Los Angeles to
London if you took a scoop of gray
matter the size of a grain of sand you
would have a hundred thousand neurons in
it with over a billion connections now
I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today your brain did this
boom that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint if
learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic people think that they want
certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh I really want to be
wealthy I want all my needs met and I'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because I want freedom
I'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion why
would you wait for your wealth to feel
free that's the Newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack and what if
I'm feeling this emotion this emotion is
influencing certain thoughts and how I
think and feel creates my life if I'm
living in lack I'm not going to create
anything new
but if I say to you hey when you become
that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the interest is in becoming that person
and we have a week with those people and
I want them to walk as it sit as it
stand as lay down I said I want them to
get in the habit of walking from their
room to the ballroom it's become the new
habit that's why when we do our work
you're we're doing sitting meditations
we're doing standing and walking
meditations we're doing lying down
meditations I want it to become a new
habit I want them to become that person
one of my biggest problems is that I
tend to react quickly to negative
situations
how can I cope with anger do you have
any suggestions or advice
yeah I'll tell you the first thing
it's not that you react we all react
the question is how long are you going
to react that's the question so
we found out that when people react
emotionally with anger with antagonism
uh there's an arousal that takes place
because you're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous systems the
Primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my God
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they they they they flee they're in fear
they're like the fear is I'm better just
getting away so they they Their Fear
causes them to run uh uh so uh when
people feel fear when they feel anger
when they feel pain those are the
primary stimulators that switch on that
sympathetic nervous system and they used
to stay
that it's automatic like it's automatic
it happens automatically that's part of
the autonomic nervous system and you
really don't have any control of it
turns out that's absolutely not the
truth so first thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and I say
Alex why are you so mad today and you
say oh it's because of this situation
and this person this happened this way
and I would say oh my gosh all right do
you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel and the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is now that's okay but if
you keep that emotional reaction going
on
for hours or days and I say to you Alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me I'm I'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago I'd say you
have a mood you're in a mood now some
people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then I would say
well Alex has a angry temperament it
becomes a temperament
if we keep it going for now this is true
people keep this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago yeah
and the research on the memory says that
50 of that story isn't even the truth
that they can't even remember the truth
they embellish the story and make it
sound worse than it really was to excuse
themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget the event
doesn't matter the details of the event
doesn't what matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused
and it starts getting frustrated and it
starts getting angry and people say I'm
doing my meditation wrong you know what
I say to them no no no no you're doing
it right because that has to come up so
then
so when the younger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if I teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and I teach you a
way to change that the brain is
organized to reflect everything you know
in your life your brain is a record of
your environment so it begs the question
does the environment control your
thinking
or does your thinking control the
environment so if you wake up every
morning and you do the same things and
you go to the same places and you see
the same people and you react in the
same way and you perform the same
behaviors it really is the external
environment that's turning on different
circuits in your brain causing you to
think equal to everything that you know
and as long as you keep thinking equal
to everything you know that's familiar
and the same according to the quantum
model you keep creating more of the same
to change then is to think greater than
our environment the think great in the
conditions in our world I have sat in
meditations and out of nowhere I had the
most icky
so familiar but so foreign feeling moved
through me that it was I don't know I
never saw it coming I didn't know what
it was
and all I did was instead of run and
turn on my cell phone or lay down or
quit I was curious if there was
something on the other side of it
so if I stay present with it and felt it
it was an energy and that energy is a
frequency and that frequency carries
information or the emotion as a memory
however you want to say it
and so you have to pass through the
valley of the shadow of Darkness many
times to find the light and I have sat
with my body curious to wonder if
there's anything on the other side of
this emotion
and if I stayed present with it and felt
it it would turn into something else in
time
and so then
think about it you know we have
different Sensations that our body
experiences you may feel like a
tightening in your throat and your
respiratory rate going up and kind of
flush
in your heart
and you may be feeling
anxious but all of those Sensations that
the body is recording your
interpretation of it is anxiety or being
anxious so the sensations then the
accumulative sensations as information
we call it an emotions the moment we
name it it's anxiety but those
Sensations that come up for the body is
information so people then sitting in
the presence of that information
and allowing you to experience it fully
will cause you to move through it now
for me
I'm all about this
if it's familiar if it's a familiar
feeling more than likely I'm back in
some unconscious program
because the emotion is driving certain
behaviors certain habits certain
thoughts now that doesn't mean that
people can't go through grieving
processes but I do believe that that
process for some people becomes a way
for them to get attention
and to get things in their life that
they need and they use it in a way that
becomes part of their identity and they
do that unconsciously
and so for me I would say then what
greater piece of knowledge could I learn
about grief or about myself that I would
want to apply to evolve my experience of
it and see if there's something on the
other side of it so
we look for those answers then and we
build a model
and for example people grieve a lot for
for people that die and I totally get it
but if you had a greater understanding
of death
you may not have said a grief for that
long because you would say my goodness
if I truly love this person if you pass
this plan and you saw someone you loved
walking around suffering what would you
say to them after a period of time
hey if you love me live your life come
on I'm going on go enjoy so I always
look what is my limited belief about
about something and could I learn to to
expand my awareness of what's possible
so if you feel the grief stay present
with it
and see by staying present with it if
there's something on the other side sit
with it long enough I I have I've had so
many dark nights and I've sat with it
until it turned into something else I
just I just was curious I didn't want
anything out there to do it
I wanted to do it and when it matters
the most is when it's the hardest that's
what I know what's emerging in the world
now because of information
is teaching people that there are other
possibilities that they were unconscious
to and you don't need an authority any
longer you don't need a priest you don't
need a governor you don't need a teacher
you don't need a doctor to gain
information any longer information is
available but the question is
what will you do with it so if you give
people sound scientific information and
science is the language of mysticism and
you combine quantum physics with
neuroscience and neuroendocrinology and
psycho neural immunology and epigenetics
and electromagnetism and make it simple
and don't talk about tradition or
religion or culture that's going to
divide an on the audience but bring the
model of Science in
person can reason and understand what
they're doing with that information
and why they're doing it then the side
effect of how they're doing it is going
to get easier and now the application
becomes essential so what we're seeing
is this the emergent Consciousness where
people are taking their power back
and not relying on anyone or anything
for their own personal change or
transformation and I think that when you
get enough people doing it emergence in
biology is a group of birds all moving
in the same direction of a school of
fish all moving the appearance is a
larger organism they're behaving in the
exact same way there's no leader when
you study that in biology everybody's
leading so how are we going to change
the world it's not one person not one
Consciousness it's a collective
Consciousness and the research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality get enough people
believing in possibility sooner or later
someone's going to run into that
experience and you need one once you
know it's possible then other people
will start doing it as well just like
the four minute mile so
so in the world right now I think we're
seeing it breaking down
of so many conventions where whether
it's religion or medicine or the
environment there's journalism
everything's falling apart right now
because it can't sustain itself because
no organisms in nature live in this kind
of abusive competition we organisms
survive in cooperation and connection
and communion
keep people in fear
keep them angry keep them in pain keep
them all all those survival emotions
you'll never have Community you bring
people into an elevated emotional state
something innate in the human species
says we're empathic to one another we
celebrate one another we want to get
along with one another we want to
cooperate we want to resolve issues
together that's that's who we are when
we're not living in stress and survival
if you think about gratitude when when
you receive something favorable or you
just receive something favorable if
something's happening to you or
something just happened to you that you
are excited about you feel grateful so
the emotional signature of gratitude
means that it's already happened or
something wonderful is happening to you
now the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between a real life experience that's
creating that emotion and that emotion
that you're fabricating by thought alone
so the body's believing it's living in
an environmental condition that's
favorable to you
and we only accept believe and surrender
to thoughts that are equal to our
emotional state so in the state of
gratitude your body is more prone to be
programmed through its autonomic nervous
system into a different Destiny and the
research that we've done uh in our in
our on our research team shows that just
four days of feeling gratitude
can strengthen your immune system by 50
percent by releasing a an immunoglobulin
called immunoglobulona which is their
body's primary defense against bacteria
and viruses is better than any flu shot
and it's the body's natural capacity so
so when we trade
anger and frustration and fear and
anxiety and pain and suffering and guilt
for an elevated emotion the autonomic
nervous system starts to regulate back
into homeostasis and balance and of
course stress is when the autonomic
nervous system is not that of
homeostasis imbalance it's dysregulation
so we teach people how to give thanks
for the things that they create in their
life actually before it happens and when
we do that properly
um we start to see measurable changes in
the person's body and measurable changes
in their energy and ultimately
measurable changes in their life so the
concept of presence is such an important
concept because I think that paying
attention is being present and it's a
skill just like anything else the more
you practice it the better you get at it
and I think we know when people are
present with us in our lives because
they're paying attention to us and we
know when they're not present with us
because they're not paying attention
well where you place your attention is
where you Glacier energy bottom line so
if you're thinking about what's going to
happen in the next moment or what's
going to happen in a day or you're
reviewing what's something that happened
three days ago you're placing your
attention in some future scenario or
some past memory and we siphon energy
out of the present moment and we don't
have available energy then to really
begin to create an outcome in our lives
but if we're truly present and we're
relaxed and poised in the present moment
if where you place your attention is
where you place your energy then you
have a lot of energy in the present
moment to execute a lot of energy in the
present moment to make decisions the
more you do this the more you experience
those moments of flow the
synchronicities the serendipities the
opportunities the coincidences because
there's a lot of power in the present
moment so one of the key elements in the
creative process is teaching people how
to relax into the present moment so if a
person is thinking about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in their brain that are connected
to certain people and objects and things
at certain times and places the moment
they think about their problems say
first thing in the morning when they
wake up
if you believe your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny and
your brain is a record of the past the
moment you remember your problems you're
thinking in the past and because every
problem has an emotion Associated
because you experience it the moment you
feel unhappy now your body's in the past
so thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so most
people unconsciously start their day
with their entire state of being
biologically in the past and again the
body's so objective it doesn't know the
difference between the real life
experience uh uh and the emotion that
you're creating by thought alone so that
past that familiar past is called the
known and if you wake up in the morning
and you start thinking about
the predictable future and the people
you have to see and the places you have
to go and the things you have to do in
your routine predictable life
the same exact thing happens you're
you're imagining that future scenario
that's already known to you
and you're anticipating the feeling of
that outcome
so that becomes the predictable future
becomes the known as well so if the
familiar past is the known and the
predictable future is the known there's
only one place where the unknown exists
and that's the sweet spot of the
generous present moment in teaching
people how to create from the present
moment is what begins to produce the
magic and the changes that take place in
their lives so think about this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things it begs the question how
much of your time and your attention do
you put on that unified field that
invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time and just
like when you're unaware of your nose it
doesn't exist and the moment you become
aware of it it exists
the quantum field is exactly the same
way if you put very little attention on
it in your waking day then it doesn't
exist for you but the moment you begin
to become aware of it the moment you
begin to pay attention to it the moment
you begin to stay present with it and to
experience it moment after moment and
where you place your attention as you
learned is where you place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand the moment you
begin to experience it not with your
senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
Consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure Consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people Beyond themselves and in fact we
know that after thousands and thousands
and thousands of brain scans that you're
at your absolute best when you get
Beyond yourself when you take your
attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go and time
itself the moment you become nobody no
one no thing no where in no time that is
the moment you become pure Consciousness
and that's the moment you begin to
connect to that field of possibilities
called the unified field or the quantum
field and that field in this invisible
field of information that exists Beyond
this space and time an independent of
the color of your skin your gender your
diet your sexual preference independent
of your profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
what's something that you've said in the
past that you were confident about it
then but now upon reflection you're like
oh I said I've changed my mind about
that oh that it takes a long time to
create reality okay I'm gonna ask you to
expand on that because I like that
answer I want to know more that's
fascinating
well um I think just like anything else
uh you learn how to snowboard you go
through that learning curve you learn
how to ride a bike you go through that
learning curve uh that that I used to
think that creation was hard I just
thought it took a lot of energy and it
took a lot of sacrifice and it'll work
for it and crayons and uh God I mean
even my definition of surrender um today
is very different than it was just three
months ago because I'm always doing it
and so I think that it doesn't have to
be that way I just think that it could
be any way you want and that and I'm
working on that changing that belief
what's called personal conviction
motivation we call these people
self-starters this is entrepreneurial
motivation
this is when you say
I'm gonna do this because I said I was
gonna do it
still a high form of motivation but not
the highest form
but what we know that people who have
purpose motivation naturally are
personally convicted
their their personal conviction is in
alignment with their purpose because
they have a reason to get up every day I
always tell my advancing students you
know when you're changing is when you
stop talking about it
because when you are truly changing
you can't go to church and shake hands
and say peace be with you and then get
in your car and cut everybody off on the
way out of the parking lot you can't say
I don't like the war in Iraq and be
arguing with your next door neighbor or
your co-worker you have to be the living
example of everything you want to see in
the world in terms of change if you
don't like greed start giving
you know you have to demonstrate and
when you do
you give people permission to do the
same because they're going to observe
you doing exactly what they're afraid to
do but they know it's the right thing to
do so the way we transform the world as
we transform ourselves
the way you transform a culture is you
transform an individual an individual by
individual when we stop looking outside
of us and we say that world is a
reflection of some aspect of me if
everybody in the world did that
simultaneously imagine how the world
would change and it's not enough to just
focus on peace yeah there's been great
studies that have shown that when a
community of people focus on peace that
the crime rate's drop but when they
leave and the research is over the crime
rates return back to the ceiling value
it's not enough to just think you got to
demonstrate it you've got to show it in
all areas of your life and when you
demonstrate it now it becomes an example
for people to follow your personality
creates your personal reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel
so the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life
so if you believe what I just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality a new life you're gonna
have to change your personality in other
words nothing changes in your life until
you change that's the way it is so turns
out the ninety percent of the thoughts
that we think on a daily basis are the
same thoughts as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry are hormones are gene
expression our immune system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same thoughts they
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep creating
the same experiences that stamp the same
networks of neurons into the same exact
patterns all for the reaffirming of the
same feeling and you do that for 10
years on end
the firing and wiring of those
circuitries begins to hardwire the brain
into a very finite signature that box in
the brain that's created is the same
level of mind and if you keep doing that
it becomes automatic
and turns out that 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we've
we've just fired and wired it the same
way so there's a good possibility then
in order for us to change we better
start thinking about what we've been
thinking about in changing we have to
become conscious of our unconscious
habits and behaviors and modify them we
got to look at these feelings that we
feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that I'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
and Neuroscience is called metacognition
the word meditation means to become
familiar with that's what it means
so the more familiar with you are I
can't with I can't it's too hard I'm
never going to change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault it's my country's
fault it's the government it's the
weather it's my pain whatever that
thought is that you accept believe and
surrender to on a daily basis that's
automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying I'm tired I'm unhappy at someone
else's fault do you complain do you
blame you make excuses do you feel sorry
for yourself that that personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you got to sit in the
fire of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say I can't meditate
or I'm going to call up my friends or
I'm gonna get on social media and make a
post I'm going to turn on the football
game I'm gonna get distracted because I
need something out there to make this go
away and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning we want you to just become
so familiar with that feeling that you
catch yourself in your waking day the
moment you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process
or breaking the habit of being the old
self process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you gotta stay conscious if you think
about great leaders in history that
change the course of many different
cultures
what they did that was so important is
they had a vision of that future
and they were able to have other people
come out of their resting emotional
state uh and begin to see that Vision
that they were seeing and move them into
an elevated emotional state and when
they changed their energy those people
could share that same vision well if you
combine a clear intention in an elevated
emotion those two ingredients change
people's state of being now the person
is just moved biologically from living
in the past to living in a new future in
the present moment and that's what
caused millions of people to begin to
make different choices to behave
differently to do different things and
if you get enough people doing that
because of mirror neurons everybody's
observing everybody do it and you create
a collective Consciousness and great
leaders have the ability to
based on core principles whether it's
Justice or Freedom or equality to have
people see that same vision and then
move them out of their resting state
into an elevated emotion and then when
they do that properly those people can
see that Vision if you can't change a
person's energy
they'll never see that Vision because
they'll be viewing the future through
the lens of the past the emotions of the
past and so great leaders have the
ability to to have people begin to see
the same vision if your personality is
made up of how you think how you act and
how you feel and it is yes or no
and you stop thinking the same way and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together every place
where one neuron connects with another
neurons called the memory
so as you begin to unfire and unwire you
prune the very circuits in your brain
that are connected to the old self and
the memory
of the old self begins to mutate begins
to change so then you would say where
is that memory stored and it's stored in
the soul now
as wisdom because you're no longer that
person yes or no
and if you could no longer behave the
same way and nerve cells that no longer
fire together no longer wire together
and pruning is part of biology you don't
use it you lose it
then your memory of the old self would
begin to change and that is a biological
death in the beginning that is
uncomfortable for a lot of people
if you're no longer feeling the same
emotions that keep you connected to the
past and you keep inhibiting that
process the body will be craving the
chemicals in the beginning because it's
been conditioned that way it's been it's
been addicted it's the mind and it's
anticipating events and the emotions
from those events and you're putting the
brakes on
and it's uncomfortable and you got to
stay conscious and it takes an enormous
amount of energy and you're no longer
signaling the same genes and producing
the same hormones and your body is no
longer being influenced by your mind in
the same way
and sometimes the mind is the biggest
enemy to the body
and you're inhibiting that process
and the body which has become the Mind
wants its way
and it's uncomfortable to change and
you've got to be able to be greater than
that to truly change in everybody that's
changed has come up against that feeling
and they almost make the same choice and
they don't and they're so glad that they
didn't
and it takes an enormous amount of
energy and awareness to do that so as
the old self
deconstructs because you have the free
will to decide who you want to be on a
moment-to-moment basis and if your life
isn't changing and you want to change
your life you got to change and now you
are playing the game and you are now
saying this personality
this person that I've become I'm in the
habit of being it and I want to become
somebody else
and the more you learn about love the
more you learn about life the more you
learn about possibility and potential
the more you become aware of it there
are more possibilities and knowledge is
the thing that gives us that
and so the old self
is a memory like another lifetime like
you can remember it but you're no longer
interested in it any longer because it
no longer defines you
how many people understand what I'm
talking about so then the biological
death of the old self is crossing a
river of change and you got to stay with
it long enough to become somebody else
and you think it's about wealth it's you
think it's about health it's about who
you become
the people who become somebody else they
they see dramatic changes in their
health and in their lives
and and they can't find the words to be
able to explain it
but it's practical though if you truly
want to change your life you have to
change yourself you would have to be
conscious of your thoughts and aware of
your actions and and familiar with those
emotions and you would never fall from
grace and if you did you would stop and
self-correct if you truly were
interested in evolution and if you said
to me it's I lost it because of that
person
I'd say that you're back to the
unconscious program of allowing your
environment to control how you feel and
think you got two choices stay there
for another six hours or pause and
change your energy change your energy
and get back to the emotions of your
future and the feelings of your future
it's a much better place to be
reason this with me
you could have a great meditation and
condition your body just like you did
into the future
you come back to your senses and you
return back to the same old self romance
in the past again
you're going to weigh that one 50-minute
one hour meditation against the rest of
the day back to you
you got to start practicing we have to
start doing it with our eyes open and
the font of who we want to become should
produce the feeling of it
instantaneously in other words the
thought of your future should produce
the feeling that it already happened
instead of the feeling of lack as it
hasn't happened
how many people understand that and the
people who do this well they condition
their body into the future and they say
I don't know how it happened it's like
my body was led right to the event and
your body is going to follow your mind
to an unknown just like it follows your
mind to the toilet every morning but
instead of it being known it's going to
be the unknown
that's where your attention and your
energy has been
I'm telling you it doesn't matter what
you believe in doesn't matter the color
of your skin what you eat I don't it
doesn't matter I've seen it in all ways
so then the thought of our future if
we're doing this properly should produce
the feeling that it already happened
if the thought of your future produces
the lack that it hasn't happened you're
still in your past and nothing is going
to change
and it would make sense then that you
would want to get that heart open on a
regular basis so that you can feel the
emotions of your future before it
happens I'm telling you there's a lot of
biology that changes in you
can you do it enough times you become
that person
the thought of it then produces the
feeling that it's already happened
that's how you know you're getting close
independent of what's going on in your
life
that's when you're mastering yourself
and mastering your life the recognition
that when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment or a
negative emotion Envy greed whatever it
may be that's actually lowering your
energy yeah and when you get to that
place where you're experiencing that
incredible Bliss right here you can you
can't yeah and even if you have the
thought the thought will still come
because we still have those thoughts
that's the thought will be an
understanding correct of human nature
because you're no longer at that
vibrational level anymore or you're
Rising above it you know and and I think
more and more people are starting to
figure that out and and and the people
in their lives are like no my husband my
husband is a changed person no he's not
the same guy I know him I know he's
completely different and the guy's just
like yeah I feel amazing I feel great
and all it was was sitting in the fire
yeah yes for a little bit of time until
the body finally moved out of the past
into the present moment and so
the causes of this like I always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing people are
they're they're they're they're getting
promotions uh they're getting all these
wonderful things not because of anything
that they're doing they're just
different yeah and people notice that
and they want those people in the
position to make better decisions for
the whole and I think that's uh that's
how we change the world in our community
at least people who have relationships
that are built uh from our community
tend to be more long-lasting because
they're more self-aware and so there's
no blame there's no excuses there's no
make wrong there's no competition
there's none of that there's just this
is who I am you know and I think that
the ultimate goal is when you reach the
point in your life when how you appear
to the world
is who you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and and you know
people say to me wow you're you're
pretty approachable and I say well God I
work so hard every day on overcoming
myself in the morning overcoming my ego
why would I want to build it up the next
day because I gotta face that guy again
tomorrow morning so why not just keep
you know you know taking those edges and
smoothing them down so that so that
you're you're less unconscious to all of
those programs that are built in
relationships in order to create a new
future
to change something in your life nothing
changes
in your life until you change that's uh
that's the story right so then the
question is okay is in order for me to
create something new I'm going to have
to combine a clear intention that's a
function of the brain and the mind
that's a a process that you can get
better at and you got to combine that
with an elevated emotion and that means
then you can't wait for your healing to
feel grateful you can't wait for your
new relationship to feel love you can't
wait for your uh um
wealth to feel abundance you know that's
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in fact
we're going to teach people actually how
to feel the emotion before it happens
and when you combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion
that's going to require your heart to
move into balance and move into order it
turns out that's a skill too that you
can practice
so then when you combine those two
elements so that clear intention with
the elevated emotion and you can sustain
that for a period of time
the coherence in the brain the coherence
and the Heart actually act like a Wi-Fi
signal you're starting to put out a
Broadband spectrum of frequency and
energy that causes you to feel connected
to something and now you're no longer
trying to get something done or waiting
for something in your outer World to
Change to take away the emptiness or
lack you're feeling because you don't
have the experience yet if people can
actually feel the feelings of the
emotions before the experience happens
they wouldn't be looking for it because
they would feel like it already happened
right so they teach people how to
sustain these states and if they can
the side effect of that is that you
start seeing synchronicities in your
life those serendipities those
coincidences those opportunities that
you're no longer going anywhere to get
them and you're not trying to control
the outcome or Force the outcome or
fight for the outcome or predict the
outcome or compete for it that's that's
when we're matter trying to change
matter when you synchronize your energy
into a possibility in your life and you
start seeing those synchronicities in
your life now when you start seeing
those opportunities occurring you're
just going to start paying attention to
what you've been doing and do more of it
and you go then from being the victim of
your life to being the creator of your
life and the cool part about it is you
don't have to go anywhere to get it
somehow out of nowhere it seems to come
to you and those moments are moments of
Awakening so the formula really is about
combining quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with psychonur Immunology with
electromagnetism epigenetics all of
these different branches of science to
build a model to show people that you
actually can be the creator of your life
I travel around the world and I have the
opportunity to talk to all kinds of
people and one of the things that
independent of people's beliefs
political beliefs religious beliefs
whatever there seems to be a Common
Thread that people feel like something's
not right
and I think when
um you get to a point where you realize
that no health care plan no government
no religion is going to take care of you
know then who is going to take care of
you and the answer is you right
so my interest is to give people the
tools and the understanding that they
could heal their body that they could
create a better life for themselves
that they could overcome past traumas
and scars that were created even as
early as childhood that tend to be
unconscious programs that keep them
repeating the same you know scenarios in
their life
to teach people how to induce mystical
experiences so that it changes the frame
of what the way they look at reality
and so what an amazing time in history
to be alive because Consciousness is
awareness
and awareness is paying attention and
paying attention is noticing so so if a
person uh lives a life as an example
and is diagnosed with a health condition
their what they're conscious of
is just a certain number of choices that
they could make based on the past based
on tradition based on what's worked for
normal or natural
but what happens when that person has
done the chemotherapy has done the
surgery has done the radiation has done
the vegan diet has done the gluten-free
diet has done the ketogenic diet has
done all the things all the exercise
and they still have the same health
condition
it begs the question
if our personality creates our personal
reality and our personality is made of
how we think how we act and how we feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life not their ex not their
parents not their culture they create
their life so the fundamental question
is if if
if I want to change my life
then that means that I have to change or
nothing changes in my life until I
change right so the person who's done
all these treatments and still faced
with a health condition this is just an
example
all of a sudden says there's got to be
another way there's got to be something
else and so knowledge information
when we learn knowledge when we learn
information we make new Connections in
our brain that's what learning is we're
forging synaptic connections
but that philosophical theoretical
intellectual information is void of
experience
someone who takes that knowledge and
applies it and personalizes demonstrates
it initiates that knowledge
is now interested in the truth of the
experience of that information
so the person then who becomes conscious
that they could actually heal themselves
by changing the way they think the way
they act the way they feel if I truly go
into the experiment of no longer
thinking the same way no longer acting
the same way no longer feeling the same
way and I start thinking about what
thoughts I do want to fire and wire in
my brain
and if I do it with intention and
attention I'll begin to install
neurological Hardware keep doing it and
becomes like a software program it
becomes a new voice in your head that
goes from I can't to I can
no magic there if you said how would
greatness live today how what would love
look like today what would be a greater
expression of myself in the things that
I do
turns out if you close your eyes and you
rehearse in your mind
how you're going to be
in any aspect of your day if you're
truly present the brain doesn't know the
difference between the inward experience
of what you're imagining and the outer
real experience it look the brain looks
like you've already done it the brain
looks like it's already experiencing now
do that enough times the hardware
becomes a software program and you start
behaving like a different person super
athletes do this this is musicians
athletes dancers everybody who's good at
something is always rehearsing in their
mind
that that rehearsal is just as important
as the physical demonstration it's
priming the brain because the brain is a
record of the past now you're actually
making it a map to the Future you're
installing circuits to use
if you said God I live my whole life in
guilt I didn't know it was guilt uh in
shame or unworthiness and self-doubt and
security fear and all of a sudden you're
looking at that emotion you understand
that emotion is actually down regulating
genes and creating disease you figure
that out you read about it it makes
sense then all of the hatred all the
anger all the bitterness you have to
someone or something in your past
is keeping you connected to the past so
you'd say
can I teach my body emotionally
what a new future could feel like before
it happens not waiting for your wealth
to feel abundance or waiting for your
relationship to feel love or waiting for
your healing to feel gratitude that's
the old model of reality of cause and
effect this is about causing an effect
turns out if you can elevate your
emotional state
and you can sustain that emotional state
your body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating that
emotion
and that emotion that you're creating by
thought alone your body's actually
believing is living in a new reality in
new environments now the environment
signals the gene the end product of an
experience in the environment is an
emotion that person is actually
signaling genes ahead of the environment
genes make proteins and proteins are
responsible for the structure and
function of the body the expression of
proteins is the expression of life okay
every day the person practices going
from the old self to the new cell this
is what's happening in the world right
now
as they start to change and they start
unfiring and unwiring and they stop
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past and practice this
they emerge as a new personality they
become somebody else and like magic
the disease exists in the old person
and there's somebody else now here's
where Consciousness comes in
that person comes to a workshop and they
stand on the stage in front of 1500
people and they tell their story
and everybody in that audience is
leaning in
why because they're looking at truth
they're looking at the example someone
who just got healed from a chronic uh
chronic I'm talking about stage four
cancers I'm talking about Parkinson's
disease I'm talking about rare genetic
disorders
and now the person in the audience is
becoming conscious
of a possibility that they were once
unconscious to And when they see that's
possible it's a four minute mile I mean
four minute mile nobody thought anybody
could break a mile and under formulas
they said it was biological yeah
physiologically impossible 1400 people
have done it already so like this is the
four minute mile someone's piercing
through a limitation a level of
unconsciousness
and now that's a footprint in the
quantum field but in three-dimensional
reality you're looking at that person
they look no different than anybody else
and the person says
if that person can do it I can do it as
well I think the ego is something that
is healthy when it's in Balance like if
I have a bonfire in my backyard and
those and the Flames are getting a
little bit too big and there's ashes and
sparks flying off the bonfire your ego
says David step back you know it's it's
preservational wants to take care of the
body if we're hiking on a cliff and we
come to a very narrow path and it's a
thousand foot drop your ego is going to
say stay close to the wall don't go out
to the edge you could be injured and be
hurt so the egos has a function to
really in a sense be analytical and and
weigh what we know against what we don't
know and it's healthy the problem is is
when it's driven by the hormones of
stress and stress is when your body's
knocked out of balance it's not that
knocked out of order that state actually
causes you to be altered and there'll
always be a gap between the way things
appear or the way you appear and the way
things really are you're in an altered
state now for the short term that's
great all organisms can tolerate that
but if you keep doing that for an
extended period of time the arousal
that's created from the stress hormones
actually causes the analytical mind all
of a sudden to go into overdrive so now
the endorsement of the ego becomes
enhanced and we become selfish that's
what it does it causes it causes us to
be self-indulgent to be self-centered to
be self-important to be
self-apprandizing to be full of
self-pity because in stress there's only
one thing that's important when you're
in survival and that's you and so all of
our attention goes on our body all of
our attention goes on all the elements
in our environment and we come become
very preoccupied with time now
when we're in balance
and there's order in the autonomic
nervous system there's health
and if stress is when you move out of
balance autonomic dysregulation then you
are altered from wholeness you are you
are separate from uh everyone and
everything in your life and you tend to
trust less it's not a time to open your
heart in the jungle the survival Gene is
switched on you you don't communicate
very well you're looking at how you can
get to where you need to be or
accomplish what you need to do first and
you got to be there first and compete
because this is all driven by those
stress hormones so the ego becomes out
of balance now here's the cool part
about all of this
when people are driven by those stress
hormones and they don't know how to
change it they don't know how to
self-regulate again it's not that you
react the question is how long are you
going to react if they don't know how to
do that the problem with most people is
they start analyzing their life
within the emotion that's disturbing
them now emotions are a record of the
past so what we see on brain scans over
and over again when you start over
analyzing and overthinking in a selfish
way
100 of the time you'll make your brain
worse and that will have dramatic
effects on your body so when the heart
is racing because it's pumping blood but
you're sitting in a zoom call and you're
smiling and you're looking at that
person a zoom call and you're thinking
about ways to murder them you're
producing those chemicals but you're not
running and you're not fighting and
you're not hiding so what happens is the
heart is pumping against a very closed
system and it moves out of order it
moves out of balance and now the
autonomic nervous system which controls
and coordinates all other systems in
your body
is out of balance in that dysregulation
causes disease so then the fundamental
question is okay can I trade fear
can I trade anger can I trade
competition can I trade frustration
resentment in patients hostility uh
hopelessness powerlessness Whatever
anxiety for an elevated emotion can I
learn how to
dial down those stress hormones and
practice feeling elevated emotions turns
out
you can do that now the real question is
when you're in your heart you're not so
selfish in fact when there's a change in
blood flow to the heart and oxytocin and
nitric oxide is released you tend to
want to give you you tend to want to
consider the whole now you lead with
your heart
you're not separate from anybody you're
you're functioning as a community so I
think then that
um our future as as human beings is that
we have to be able to live in an
elevated state in our hearts and if we
fall from grace back into those survival
emotions the key is to be able to
self-regulate and get so good at it in
your meditation with your eyes closed so
good at it that you can do it with your
eyes open now that's when the game
becomes really really important so uh
when people do the work and they do
their meditations and they come up
against themselves gosh I want them to I
want them to come up against their fear
and in the in the week-long workshops I
want them to come up against their
impatience I want all those thoughts
that come up that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change it's my ex's
fault it's my boss's fault I want those
thoughts to be right in their face and I
want to give them tools to let them know
that right on the other side of that
that thought right on the other side of
that propensity to want to get up and
quit right on the other side of that
emotion that's keeping them connected to
the past if they're willing to sit in
the fire
to sit with themselves and instead of
getting up and quitting on themselves
learn how to self-regulate and create
brain and heart coherence I guarantee
you every time they go a little further
and they produce those victories of
those victories add up so what's the
side effect of that you return back to
your life you don't need jerk as much
why because you just overcame some part
of your aggression and anger by sitting
with your body and like training an
animal
training a dog I don't know training the
servant to be present to to to to to to
be greater than the body as the mind to
execute a will that's greater than those
unconscious programs and what we found
out is when people actually apply some
type of formula to be able to do this
every time they bring the body back into
the present moment it starts liberating
energy
so there it goes the frustration there
goes the impatience and all of a sudden
the unknown which tends to be such a
scary place for most people is the
present moment you see the side effect
of that is the person's more present
they're less preoccupied with all the
things that people spend most of their
attention on now so you overcome the ego
you overcome the personality uh uh
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
that you've got to be able to lay it
down
and as you temper your body and your
mind
um the ego tends to be less selfish and
more selfless and then the side effect
of that is that then if I say hey look
at David he's actually doing it I'm
gonna try it too because he's he's doing
it and research and Neuroscience says
you hang out with people that do things
you start your brain synchronizes and
you start doing those same things it's
called an emergence emergence that's the
birds all moving in the same direction
it's a school of fish moving as one mind
and one heart if you study that you
think there's one leader like that
everybody's following a leader like a
top-down phenomenon it's actually wrong
it's a bottom-up phenomenon everybody's
leading so the way we change the world
then is that you work on yourself I'll
work on myself we get to show up and
bring our best and when we're not at our
best we excuse ourselves get back to
that state and we present ourselves back
to the world and I think this is such a
great time in history where people
really need some tools to be able to
cope with with all the challenges in the
world I think there's this feeling
um that we all have
that never seems to go away and it's an
intuition it's an instinct that tells us
that there's more to reality than this
dream yeah and and I think that people
come to this work for that feeling
and I think that we're greater than we
think more powerful than we know more
unlimited uh than we could ever dream
and my passion
my interest is to take science and
combine quantum physics with
Neuroscience with neuroendocrinology
with
psychoneuroimmunology with uh the
epigenetics electromagnetism and I think
science is that language to demystify
the mystical
and to build models of understanding
from a theoretical and intellectual
knowledge-based analytical perspective
but
that knowledge void of experience is
philosophy but if you can teach people
how to practically apply it to to
personalize it to demonstrate it to
initiate that knowledge and do something
with it
if they can get their behaviors to match
their intentions or their actions equal
to their thoughts if they get their mind
and body working together they're going
to have an experience right and turns
out that learning information makes
Connections in the brain but experience
enriches those connections well the
moment there was neurons string into
place there's a biological change that
takes place in the brain another part of
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called an emotion and the
moment you feel successful the moment
you feel empowered the moment you feel
Unlimited
I think now you're teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood so knowledge
is for the mind and experiences for the
body and so what we learned in this
whole process of transformation is that
the more people understand what they're
doing
and why they're doing it the how gets
easier so when the experience then is
causes them to embody the truth of that
philosophy it's no longer theoretical
it's experiential and it's visceral so
the experience then
produces a strong emotion and the
emotion then is what is the information
coming uh back to the body that begins
to select and instruct new genes and
we've measured this on people that they
could actually change their gene
expression in in three or four days by
doing this now if you've done it once
it means you got to be able to do it
again right so anybody who's serious
about their own personal growth and
evolution
the replication of any experience will
begin to both neurologically and
chemically condition the mind and body
to work as one so when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind now it's innating you
it's implicit it's automatic it's second
nature it's easy you've become the
knowledge and in a sense you've mastered
that knowledge and you're in a new state
of being so
my interest is demystify that process so
that people have within their reach all
the tools begin to apply it to their
lives if you think that your thoughts
have something to do with your future
just from a theoretical standpoint that
your thoughts Create Your Destiny and
you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day and 90 of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before
well then your life isn't going to
change very much as long as you're
thinking the same way and those those
same thoughts lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
exact same experiences and we anticipate
the same feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neural circuitry
our neural chemistry
our hormones and even our gene
expression will be equal to how we think
how we act and how we feel and how we
think how we act and how we feel is
called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits that creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
gonna begin to hardwire certain patterns
in your brain that becomes your identity
and by the time we're 35 years old it
kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then
that kind of box in the brain that is
the habit of ourselves it's the uh we're
95 of the time running a series of
programs so then sitting and doing the
work we have to become disentangled from
those programs and so the moment you
decide to do something differently or
make a new choice but most people don't
want to face is that discomfort and that
that discomfort that that uncertainty
that lack of predictability the that
that that unknown is what people are
afraid of because they'd rather live in
guilt at least they can predict who
they're going to be then take a chance
and possibility so when a person begins
to understand this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically
but when you step out into that unknown
into that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they'd rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy
then be in this this comfort so then at
least then when they return back to that
familiar feeling then they feel safe so
they step out in the unknown and the
body starts influencing the mind saying
you can start tomorrow you're too busy
it's your mother's fault you know it's
your culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then
to understand that there's a formula
that we now know that if you apply that
formula you'll begin to see those
changes and now as people are doing it
more and more effectively
the results are going up as well we just
had Bond University they just took a
whole bunch of my brain scans from 10
years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
the community can change brain or heart
coherence they they know how to do it
it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple
in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest scans are
people who just have never meditated
before that are not trying to do
anything they just follow instructions
so so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and we do a
week-long event we got a thousand people
or 1500 people and they are all in and
that when they start getting Beyond
themselves that first day or second day
once they start getting Beyond
themselves
and that magic starts to happen then I
have no idea I can't predict what's
going to happen next and it's usually
pretty pretty exciting we do have
beliefs that feel good to us because
those beliefs are based on past
experiences and those emotions keep us
attached to the belief chemically it's
in our biology and we tend to think
neurologically and feel chemically
within experiences then that are
connected to the past so when our
beliefs are challenged we hold on to the
emotion like Jesus had a brother what
that doesn't feel right you know he was
married to Mary Magdalene you know I
mean people freak out because they've
been conditioned and they want to hold
on to that because that then ensures a
future that they can rely on
when you step out of your belief systems
and stepping into the unknown
you are now leaving behind your past and
then so then do you have the faculty
and the ability to create
do you have that ability if not because
then in order for you to go from that
Old belief to a new belief then you
better have a plan and you better be
willing to have a new experience that is
no longer a wishy-washy belief
it has to be a very strong impression in
your biology it comes with an
accompanying experience
that then changes your biology to
understand you believe something else
but that's not the end either because
then you have the question from that
point
what is the next belief that helps you
to understand the next thing for example
with talk about it on two levels and
time out here for a second I don't care
or you can go to 11 30 here oh beautiful
thank you so much it was a good
conversation so think about this
the person in our work
who I'll use a simple example
has a uh very very difficult marriage
and her marriage falls apart her husband
was abusive
and lived by the stress hormones for
extended period of time of course all
our energy is going for some threat in
our external environment she has no
energy in in her internal environment
for growth and repair no energy for
long-term building projects the the body
is in vigilance it's it's always anxious
she's anticipating something bad
happening all the time and she's got
food allergies to
everything
she's allergic to her environment
she comes to the event she does the work
it takes her three months and all of a
sudden in one event she has a
breakthrough and she's eating anything
she wants now she's changed her belief
about her past because she's no longer
saying I am this way because of my
relationship with my husband because
when you say I am this way because I had
an abusive father I am this way because
I had a difficult marriage I am this way
because I got fired from my job what
you're saying is I haven't changed since
that event emotionally
and so now you're viewing your future
through the lens of the past when you
overcome that emotional state a memory
without the emotional charge is called
wisdom
now you're ready to create a new future
because if you're still attached to the
emotion you're still attached to the
past and you can't create a future so
all of a sudden now the person has a
transformation
she had a shift she knows that she knows
that she's liberated from that anxiety
she's she feels it and as a result of it
in a matter of moments Ben or biology
reorganizes to a new mind and now she's
eating I'm watching her eat pizza I'm
watching her eat a hamburger she's
laughing she's and it's and it's
sustained
but that's not the end because if she
healed herself then the next question is
I understand the physics and biology of
what I've done is it possible if I heal
myself
but I can heal another person
now my my belief is being challenged
again now I'm challenging my current
belief is it possible well I don't know
I haven't had the experience yet but if
I'm thinking it and I understand the
semantic philosophical theoretical
intellectual information can I initiate
it can I apply it can I personalize it
can I demonstrate it can I modify my
behavior in some way based on my last
experience to have a more evolved
experience and that more evolved
experience will be outside of my beliefs
currently but I understand the science
and if I can get my behaviors to match
my intentions and I've done it to myself
and quantum physics says is that
Consciousness is non-local will help if
I can create a coherent signature here I
should be able to do it in another
person
so then when the when the experience
occurs
now I have more circuitry in my brain
that's enriched I have a new feeling in
my body and I feel like a Healer I
already feel like a Healer because I've
healed myself but let me see if I can
heal someone else I'm going to bring up
that emotion and it may take me a few
times and I'm telling you that woman we
did a coherent session where we're
healing another person and the person
laying down there was a woman who from
London who had a exposure to a bacteria
in India 20 years ago who had food
allergies That Couldn't overcome that
bacteria and I watched this woman
synchronistically
unbeknownst to the woman laying down
there lay a coherent energy in that
person's body and that woman was healed
I had dinner with her in London and she
was eating salmon and rice and
everything else and she said I don't
know what happened but I got healed now
that person who did the healing
her belief was challenged and because
she had the experience she asked the
greater question so the greater question
then led to the next experience but it's
not enough to do it once
you got to be able to repeat that
experience you got to make it scientific
right you got to get it you got to make
it a skill and this is where people stop
like they have the one experience and
say I'm a Healer no
the fact that you have the experience
means you should be able to reproduce
that
so then you keep pushing the boundaries
of your beliefs that's called Evolution
and so people reach a certain point in
their belief systems and they stop and
so I think the problem with a lot of
people in the spiritual Community is
they confuse Insight with belief like oh
you know I had a I have an I have
anxiety so the reason I have anxiety
because I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain that's what my doctor told me
and I get panic attacks and I got a
panic attack on a plane and I'm afraid
of planes and crowded places and so now
that you know that you have a chemical
imbalance in your brain does it heal
your anxiety no so then they go to the
they go to the psychologist they go to
their friend their friends says well
it's not a hardware problem it's not
circuits and molecules and chemicals
software problem you know your father
was overbearing he was a perfectionist
and and some softens of programming you
know it's from your past and
the person now has the insight
that their father was overbearing does
it heal the anxiety but they will see
that as a belief like my father was
overbearing which they're really saying
is I am this way because of this past
experience so then they go to the
psychic and the psychic says you were
burned at the stake in Carcassonne in
the 1500s you're a Charismatic Christian
the memories burned in your soul now
that you know that you are a Charismatic
Christian from the 1500s a cathar a
Templar does it heal your anxiety no so
then you go to the astrologer and she
says you know America use in retrograde
don't leave the house for six months
it's the reason Ari the way you are the
way you are and so they develop beliefs
that are within their emotional
acceptance and so then they build more
beliefs within those emotions which
means I still don't want to change the
Insight doesn't change anything because
people will only accept believe and
surrender
to beliefs or thoughts that are equal to
their emotional state and they'll
program their autonomic nervous system
into that Destiny so then you get a
diagnosis from a doctor it creates the
emotion of fear or desperation you'll
only accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to those emotional states
until you change your emotional state is
it possible for you then to begin to
accept believe and surrender their
thoughts equal to a new emotional state
and bring up the emotion ahead of the
experience now we're talking about
going against conditioning when you
teach people how to connect to the
energy of a future dream and be defined
by a vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past to believe in their
future more than they believe in their
past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
a victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life can
you teach your body emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something in
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice I've seen people with Strokes for
10 years lift their arms up again we've
seen people step out of wheelchairs
people on crutches drop their cracks I
mean you see
and the body literally recalibrates to a
new mind and and they're not
intentionally trying to do anything
they're just becoming somebody else but
the process of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease I think it's a time in
history where it's not enough to know
it's a time in history to know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think 60 to
70 000 thoughts in one day and ninety
percent of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern so then the
hardest part about change really in
creating the life that you want being
defined by a vision of the future
instead of a memory of the past is not
making the same choices you did the day
before and the moment you do that you
step into the unknown now you and I have
been conditioned and hypnotized into
believing that the unknown is some scary
place but when you begin to realize the
unknown is the perfect place to create
from that void of unpredictability and
uncertainty that unfamiliarity is really
the quantum place of uncertainty where
all manifestations come from so when you
and I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past
and if you feel the same way every
single day and feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences it
means number one nothing new is
happening in your life and number two
those emotions are keeping you anchored
to the past if thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being most people are literally
biologically neurologically chemically
genetically and even Quantum wise
connected to a past so then the question
is the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our bodies Our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes in new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever whatever
caused that that's that's cause and
effect and when you begin to make the
correlation between what changed you
from outside and inside you create an
associate of memory the quantum model of
reality begins to say then you have to
teach your body emotionally how that
future is going to feel like before it's
made manifest in other words you have to
feel awe in order for the mystical
moment to happen you have to feel a
abundance before your wealth can occur
you have to feel in love with life
before your new relationship happens and
so we're not defining Reality by our
senses because we're not waiting then
for anything outside of us to change how
we feel inside of us so if there's
physical evidence in your brain and body
to look like the experience has already
occurred physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect the
survival emotions the emotions that are
derived from the hormones of stress are
very addictive
anger is addictive fear is addictive
sadness is addictive resentment is
addictive competition is addictive
frustration is addictive all of those
emotions that are derived from the
hormones of stress give the brain and
body A Rush of energy so if an addiction
is something you can't stop and you
happen to have a friend or a family
member who's walking around suffering
every single day of their life and you
say to them why don't you stop or you
you're in the middle of an angry
experience and I say to you Michael why
don't you just stop being angry if you
can't stop
you can't stop that that on some level
you're addicted because an addiction is
something you can't stop so when people
start to understand oh my God I'm
addicted to my own frustration I'm
addicted to my own suffering I'm
addicted to my own guilt all of a sudden
they start becoming conscious of what
they're doing to their brain and body
show them how those very chemicals down
regulate genes to create disease
and then get them beyond that by doing
meditation that's the moment then all of
a sudden they begin to be greater than
their biology and we've measured this
thousands of times in people and it's
without a doubt I can say this from
every single cell in my being that a
person is at their absolute best when
they get Beyond themselves that's the
bottom line seventy percent of the time
people living by the hormones are stress
whether they know it or not they're
always anticipating the future based on
the past they're always having their
attention on objects and people and
things and places in the world because
that's where the danger is the chemicals
are jacking up their body so their
attention is on their body so they think
based on their own experience that
they're their body but they're not they
believe that they're their identity
that's connected to relationships of
people and things and places in their
life but they're not then when people
start to live on autopilot and they get
out of bed the same way and they brush
their teeth of the same hand and they do
all the same things every single day and
they've been doing that for 20 or 30
years for the most most part then their
bodies on autopilot it's in a
predictable future based on what it's
done in the past so very few people are
in the present moment so then they're
locked into a line of time a linear line
of time where their future and their
past seem to be exactly the same so no
not a lot of people are present or in
the present moment and if you're not in
the present moment I assert that you're
running some type of program which means
you're not present the body's already
programmed to be in the future in the
past so then
in the elegant moment of meditation and
we've we can predict this now on a brain
scan there comes a moment where a person
forgets about their body
they forget they're they're so involved
in their inner world that there is
nobody
they forget that they are an identity
they're not paying attention to the
people they know and the places they go
and the things they have to do or the
things they own they become no one they
become no thing they go to nowhere and
they forget about their appointments and
their past and they become no time and
that is the moment they become pure
Consciousness that is the moment that
they begin to disconnect from their
biology and who you are to answer that
question is a Consciousness that's
manipulating the brain and body to
produce different levels of mind
and only when you are pure consciousness
can you begin to change your body
only when you are beyond your body can
you heal your body you can't the body
can't heal the body you have to get
beyond your body to heal your body in
order for you to create some new
experience in your life you got to get
beyond the problems in your life in
order for you to create some new future
event in some future time you got to get
Beyond predictable linear time and so if
you're going to heal your body by
thought alone if you're going to create
some experience in your life by thought
alone if you are going to create some
new event in your future by thought
alone then you have to become thought
alone and that is the moment when you
become pure Consciousness where you are
nobody no one no thing nowhere in no
time that is the moment
that you're no longer constrained by
those laws that is the moment your
Consciousness freewilled subjective
human consciousness merges with the
quantum field the objective Universal
Consciousness and when they come
together and you come back to awareness
you take a piece of it with you and you
become more like it you become more
willful it has an amazing will you
become more mindful it has an infinite
mind become more conscious it has a
great Consciousness you become more
loving it's a it's a love it's a lover
of life you become more Giver giving
it's a giver of life it's it's nature
becomes your nature and so teaching
people how to do that uh is the art so
then when you understand that you we we
we now know that there are certain ways
to do that that help people get there
faster according to the psychological
and scientific model
the majority of people in their waking
day in a normal day spend about 70
percent of their time living in stress
and living in stress is living in
survival
and the actual definition of stress
stress is when your body's not that of
homeostasis
balance
the stress response is what your body
innately does to return itself back to
order you have three types of stress you
have physical stress like trauma
injuries accidents Falls you have
chemical stress like bacteria viruses
blood sugar levels heavy metals and
Foods hangovers whatever
and you have emotional stress like
traffic jams internet connections second
mortgages single parenting 401ks family
tragedies all of those things knock the
brain and body out of balance
now all organisms in nature can adapt to
short-term stress
pack of coyotes chases a deer in the in
the forest the deer outruns the coyotes
the stress is over the theory turns back
to homeostasis and it grazes again the
event is over when the deer perceives a
threat in its external environment it
turns on a primitive nervous system
called the fight-or-flight nervous
system
and that autonomic nervous system that
sympathetic nervous system begins to
mobilize enormous amounts of energy for
some threat in the external environment
now the year has all its physiology
changed all the blood is sent to the
extremities heart rate increases
respiratory rate rate increases pupils
dilate dilate the 1300 chemicals that
are created in a matter of seconds is to
cause the deer to survive in some
difficult condition
now
human beings have the same mechanisms
and when we perceive a threat in our
external environment like a lion we are
going to run or fight or freeze
but if you've had problems with your
co-worker
or you've had a very difficult
experience with your mother-in-law
the moment you perceive your
mother-in-law or your co-worker you and
you have a past experience with them
you're going to turn on the same
primitive nervous system
just like you're being chased by a lion
so what was once highly adaptive now
becomes very maladaptive because when
you're mobilizing all of that energy
you are going to operate in very
predictable ways you're going to be an
amped up animal with a big memory bank
so that your blood flow is going to go
to the hind brain and away from the
forebrain which means you're going to
react instead of think
rationalize
but human beings the privilege of being
a human being is that we can make
thought more real than anything else
that's the privilege
so then you can begin to forecast
some future worst case scenario
and you can attend to that thought to
the exclusion of everything else and you
can focus on it to such a degree that
you will begin to anticipate the event
and produce the same chemicals as if
you're in that experience and you're
knocking your brain and body out of
balance just by thought alone
you can begin to unfold some past bitter
memory that's tattooed in the recesses
of your gray matter and like magic you
can bring it to life and in that moment
it's real and you will produce the same
chemistry in your brain and body as if
that event occurred and your body is the
unconscious mind is literally living
that experience
so then when we're living by the
hormones of stress and you turn on that
stress response and you can't turn it
off now you're headed for some disease
because no organism in nature can
tolerate living in emergency mode for
extended periods of time so if seventy
percent of the time a person is living
in survival living in stress in survival
what we do in order to survive
as we are going to select the worst case
scenario
and we are going to begin to plan our
behaviors and our emotions in that
experience because anything less than
the worst case scenario means we have
better chances of survival so we plan
for the worst we emotionally embrace it
and anything less means we can survive
so out of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field
anxiety really represents a poor
imagination but it's highly adaptive if
it's if you're living in survival
because you got to get ready for that so
seventy percent of the time people are
selecting the worst case to vent in
their life and emotionally embracing it
and they're they're programming their
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny and turns out if you
keep doing that and you create the
emotions of fear and worry and anxiety
and you do that for 10 years or five
years or three years your body is going
to unconsciously become programmed to
fear and it's going to have a panic
attack without you try as you may with
your conscious mind to control it you've
programmed it subconsciously and now the
body as the mind is running the show
so
the hormones of stress
create the emotions of anger
of aggression of hostility of violence
of frustration of hatred of fear of
anxiety of guilt of Shame of
hopelessness of powerlessness depression
those are all chemicals that are derived
from the hormones of stress and when we
live by the hormones of stress we become
very selfish why because when you're in
survival you've got to take care of the
self your tension is on your body right
your attention is on your external
environment there's Predators out there
the the rush of adrenaline causes the
senses to become heightened and you're a
materialist and you're trying to predict
the future because there's better
chances of survival if you can predict
the future based on the past when that
occurs then over time
the body begins to break down because
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes to create disease in the
long term
so if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone
and the hormones of stress can make you
sick
then your thoughts can literally make
you sick so the question is if your
thoughts can make you sick
is it possible then that your thoughts
can make you well the hormones of stress
push the genetic buttons that create
disease if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone
your thoughts could make you sick and if
your thoughts could make you sick is it
possible that your thoughts could make
you well so they began to realize that
oh my God the repetition of thinking and
feeling and feeling and thinking caused
me to feel guilt and I don't even know
it's guilt it just feels like me it's
just I'm used to the same chemical
continuity now the moment they decided
to change anytime you decide to change
and change anything about yourself get
ready because it's going to feel
uncomfortable It's Gonna Hurt You're
Gonna Leave The Gnome yeah you're gonna
leave the familiar and you're gonna step
into the unknown even if the familiar is
uncomfortable and painful right you
still can be painful leaving the pain
right because some people are super
happy being unhappy right so then they
would rather cling to their suffering
than take a chance and possibility so
these people said I really have nothing
to lose right
so then they said I'm willing to be
uncomfortable and be in the unknown and
it turns out that's the perfect place to
create from so when the body is
conditioned to become the mind then to
change is to be greater than the body
right because we become greater than the
body well that's a whole nother
conversation but let me finish this okay
so the third thing they said was
okay so now that I know that I got to
break the habit of being myself and I
can't mismanage my thoughts and feelings
I gotta change how I act I gotta Watch
How I speak I got to become conscious of
how unconscious I am because 95 of Who
We Are by the time we're 35 years old
it's a set of memorized behaviors like a
computer program emotional reactions
unconscious beliefs and perceptions so
the first step to change
is to become conscious of how you think
to notice how you act to pay attention
to how you feel and the act of observing
those states of Mind and Body separates
you from that program now you're you're
the Consciousness observing that program
it turns out the more conscious you
become of how unconscious you are you
know lighting a match in a dark place
that first step creates enormous amounts
of Chaos in the brain and body and it's
disturbing so people just go back to the
same addiction the same emotion the same
problem this feels better no that feels
familiar so they said okay now I'm not
going to change I gotta reinvent myself
now this is really important because
they started sitting down and thinking
Okay who in history do I admire we're
great people role models that I can
follow what are the qualities and
characteristics that they have how am I
going to change you know these are what
we call frontal lobe questions the
creative center of the brain switch is
on an emotional Center settles down
so then they started thinking
I have to be in a new life if I was
really going to heal what would I have
to change about myself
now there's this interesting phenomenon
that if you close your eyes
and you begin to think about doing
something you're an athlete you
understand this if you're a background
in football and you are running a
pattern or you are doing something you
would rehearse it in your mind turns out
that the act of mentally rehearsing
something when you're truly present
your brain does not know the difference
between what's going on out there and
what's going on in here in fact your
brain will begin to look like you've
been doing it for the last five days and
you've never run the course so now your
brain is no longer a record of the past
because typically it is now it's a map
to the Future so now you're priming your
brain so that became the very platform
you know experiments with piano players
you know you take a group of people that
never played the piano before you divide
them into two different categories I
think one group of people you teach them
one-handed scales and courts you do a
brain scan on them they come and
practice for two hours a day for five
days at the end of five days if you
rescan the brain they grow new circuits
on the opposite side of the brain
nothing magical there you learn
something new learning's making new
connections get some instruction you get
instruction you get your body involved
get your body involved you're gonna have
an experience experience in which is the
brain pay attention to what you're doing
you got to pay attention and repeat it
firing and wiring here to assemble new
circuits you can take the other group of
people have them come for two hours a
day for five days do a brain scan before
the brain scan after have them close
their eyes and mentally rehearse playing
those scales and chords
at the end of five days they'll grow the
same amount of circuits and their brain
as the people who actually physically
demonstrated the action what does that
mean it means not only they change their
brain by thinking differently but their
brain looks like they've been playing
the piano for five days now set them in
front of a piano never play the piano
before they'll play those scales and
chords because their brain is wired to
play it so now the act of rehearsing who
they're going to be
what are the qualities I'm beginning to
get in this creative state began to lay
down the circuits of a new personality
and a new personality is connected to a
new personal reality so the next
question is does that change the body
take a group of men have them do
one-handed
curls in their mind and bring an
emotional component like stronger harder
more intense one hour a day for two
weeks at the end of two weeks 13.5
increase in muscle strength wow never
lifted away now their body is changing
by thought a lot so these people began
to reprogram their brain and body
and all of a sudden they began to act
differently why because they installed
the circuits they began to think
differently of course they began to feel
differently they they were no longer
feeling pain they're actually liking
themselves right so that if they're
living by a different emotion and
they're they're feeling an elevated
emotion before their healing before they
were healed they're not waiting for
their healing to feel Joy and gratitude
they're feeling gratitude and joy now
their bodies believing that it's healed
because the body's feeling the emotion
ahead of the experience and if the
environment signals the Gene and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is in motion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and what do genes do genes
make proteins so what are proteins
responsible the structure and function
of the body now you're literally
becoming somebody else and now you're
turning down the genes for disease and
you're turning up these other genes so
I started to realize that this
reinvention process is exactly what
we've always done it's just that we get
complacent in certain areas of our life
and we stop let's say you've had some
pretty rough experiences in your past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember 95 percent of who you
are is your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually complain
unconsciously because your body does it
all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people I'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body starts sending signals to the
brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
the thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
's a better day
this is too hard for me I can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault I'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one this doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought is if it's true
that thought leads to the same Choice
which leads to the same behavior that
creates the same experience that
produces the same emotion and the person
says this feels right
that feels familiar
going from the old self to the new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty is the biological the
neurological the chemical the hormonal
genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us well in that
unknown I can't predict my life or my
future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it not from the known but from
the unknown
and when you and I get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens and it never happens
in the known if you have a very brain
driven person like myself
and in some parts I disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that I already had in
circumstances that would help
um do you have any advice
yeah well uh God I have a lot of advice
around that because
um
70 of the time that people in their
waking lives
they live in a very protective State
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program that we don't know that we're
doing this we're always
expanding the environment to determine
if it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us and we move into a
state of arousal and we begin to turn on
the very systems that begin to say
danger threat possible scenario that's
not safe
and when that happens we literally begin
to anticipate an outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety worry sadness pain when we do
that unconsciously that's what a program
is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide
show a certain amount of success and be
competitive then you're not going to
open your heart it's not a time to do
that it's a time to survive and thrive
in an environment
and yet in our work I see men that if
they practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go we're
all faced with
uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations and there's
always a door there is always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means if you're going to change
something in your personal reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
the thought of changing my personality
seems so like but I like who I am kind
of but I'm also cranky I'm also annoyed
so like who is that person underneath
all of these ailments I guess all of
these but it's a weird thing to say you
change your personality
well look I mean there's many things
that I love about my personality just
like you do I'm gonna take that with me
but there are things if I'm going to be
defined by a vision of the future
they're things that can't come because
the moment you say I want to have a
mystical experience where I transcend
this three-dimensional world and and you
want to have a really profound moment a
transcendental moment you start showing
up for that and it doesn't happen right
away then what you're going to start
disbelieving you start but stop
believing yourself so so the moment
we're defined by a vision of the future
that's bigger than us that vision of the
future is not the vision of the past and
when we do that we take away we take
with us our discipline we take our
concentration we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us all those things you
take but the things that are standing in
the way are those old beliefs are things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and so many great people
in history you know even wealthy people
people always want to be wealthy but if
you study wealthy people that really did
it they failed miserably thousands of
times until they figured it out and so
you keep showing up for yourself enough
times
You're Gonna Change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation let's
demystify the present moment okay people
wake up in the morning and they they
think about their problems and those
problems or memories that are etched in
their brain they're connected to certain
people and objects at certain times and
places the moment they wake up in the
morning and they start thinking of the
problems they're thinking in the past
okay now every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with it so when
they feel unhappy when they feel bitter
when they feel fearful now their bodies
in the past thoughts are the language of
the brain feelings of the language of
the body thought and a feeling image and
emotion stimulus and response you're
conditioning the body to be the mind of
that emotion subconsciously now the body
is believing it's living in the same
past experience 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year why because
the body's so objective it doesn't know
the difference between the real life
experience that's creating that emotion
and the emotion that person is creating
by thought alone important
the environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics the end product from an
experience in the environment is an
emotion the person's signaling the same
genes in the same way and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of your
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of Life another person is
actually headed for a genetic Destiny
and when people labor
for the present moment
and they take their attention off of
their body off of all the people in
their life all of the objects they own
their cell phone their computer their
car their house they're no longer
identifying with where they're sitting
where they need to be where they live
where they've lived in the past where
they need to go and they're not thinking
about the predictable future of the
familiar past
they're dissociating from everything
physical and material everything known
that is the exact moment we call getting
Beyond yourself okay now
when we're in that place then at the
beginning it's uncomfortable because
we're survival is the unknown you better
chances of survival and running from the
unknown but that unknown is the perfect
place to create from so in the process
no different than any rehab in our first
two days of our event really people are
they're basically they're basically
rehabbing from their emotional states
and their habits and they're sitting in
the presence of that discomfort right
and the discomfort is because the body
is leaving the known but but but
the body has been conditioned to be the
mind the moment you take it outside of
its familiar territory it's going to
start telling you Ed why don't you quit
you know you're not really good at this
you know you're more of a physical
person you don't really want to do this
you're not very this or very that and
most people just get up on their do
their meditation they believe that
thought as if it's true now the question
is what's on the other side of that
thought can you sit there long enough
till that's no longer the thought you
accept believe and surrender to
well then wow the next question inside
of that thought what is the other what's
on the other side of that familiar
emotion can I sit and work with my body
and settle it down stay you stay I'm
gonna feed you you're not gonna die from
this your bladder's not going to explode
you're not going to go crazy and you
work with catching those thoughts it's
called metacognition if you're in that
95 of programming where you're
unconscious
and the first step to change is becoming
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you're so conscious that you would never
go unconscious or let that thought slip
by you unnoticed I want to understand so
you're saying the awareness of the
thought being conscious of the thought
has it somehow lose its power over you
exactly exactly because just because you
have a thought doesn't mean it's true
and if you're left alone to yourself
you'll start believing every thought you
think and that's the problem so then the
majority of people's thoughts then are
based on what they perceive about
themselves from their past or their life
right and if you catch yourself
complaining and blaming and making
excuses and judging someone else and you
say I want to be a happy person well a
happy person would never do that would
make them unhappy if you notice that
you've been feeling guilty for the last
20 years you didn't know it was guilt
because it just felt like you and you
want to feel Joy well if you can feel
Joy it should tell us volumes about what
you've been practicing doing right so
then most people give up because
they they don't know that there's
anything on the other side of it so then
the next question is
what thoughts do you want to fire and
wire in your brain well and with
attention and with intention
if you keep practicing firing wiring
those thoughts you start installing
Hardware do it enough times and it
becomes like a software program and now
that's the new voice you program in your
head that said I can do this I believe
in myself and you've created to an
extent a new personality which can
create a new personal reality now here
we go so then the next question is how
am I going to behave with my kids today
how am I going to be with my wife how am
I going to be with my partner I'm going
to be at work I might be on my zoom
calls I'm going to be by myself how am I
going to what what does greatness look
like what would love do today now it
turns out that if you close your eyes
and you start imagining doing that if
you rehearse how you're going to be in
those certain situations the evidence
without a doubt shows that your brain
will start to look like through the
mental rehearsal of the act that you've
already done it now you've installed the
hardware keep doing it it becomes a
software program and you'll start acting
like a happy person no magic there if
you don't have the circuits you can't do
it so the rehearsal then
is actually changing the brain just by
thinking differently the brain looks
like the experience has already happened
now you have Hardware to use do it
enough times you get good at it becomes
more automatic now here's the hard part
can I teach my body emotionally
what my future will feel like before it
happens now this is really important
because there's a pandemic going on in
the world that has nothing to do with a
virus that has everything to do with
people's attention span and learning
people need a rush of dopamine in order
to catch their attention or a rush of
adrenaline to learn and so that they're
they're dependent on their outer
environment to regulate their emotional
state now this is different now now I'm
going to say to you
get in that beautiful heart of yours and
I want you to feel gratitude for the
event before it occurs well I can feel
it because it hasn't happened yet that's
the conditioning that's the hypnosis
anxiety is doing this living in the
survival when you're living in survival
I'll tell you this when the survival
Gene is activated out of the infinite
Potentials in the quantum field
you'll always choose the worst case
scenario why because if you're in
survival and you're preparing for the
worst there's always better chances of
surviving if anything less happens so
people are always selecting the worst
thing in their mind and they begin to
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens thought and emotion you start
conditioning so you're conditioning the
body to become the mind of fear you keep
doing that enough times once the body
becomes the mind it's a subconscious
program a person has a panic attack try
as you made a control with your
conscious mind you can't you programmed
it subconsciously now you worry about
the next panic attack and as you start
worrying about the next panic attack
it's the vigilance that creates the next
one wow now here's what's happening in
our work
people who are self-regulating and
creating these elevated States we have
we have heart scans of them sustaining
hard coherence for a whole hour during a
meditation then at the end of the day
they're still wearing the monitor it's
eight o'clock at night they're not even
in a meditation and for a whole entire
hour they're on hard coherence we say to
the woman uh what's going on here she
said I have no idea I was just getting
ready for bed and all of a sudden my
heart just swelled up it was so intense
I had to lay on my back and surrender to
love WoW instead of surrendering to fear
she had a spontaneous love attack
instead of a spontaneous panic attack
now I would call that the natural state
of being so then
if you're living by those elevated
States and you know how to feel that
emotion off your future before it
happens
you're less likely to wait for it to
happen because you'll feel like it
already happened you'll less likely try
to control it you'll know that the
moment you lose the feeling you just
disconnected and you're going to make
your way back when you get good at it no
person no thing no experience can take
it away from you now you're empowered
and if you understand the laws of how
creation happens then you're less likely
to compete and rush to get what you want
you're going to know that it's going to
come to you and now that's the new model
of how we create so now we had a guy
that came in a wheelchair an event we
did recently
it came in that Throne he walked from he
had ALS he walked from the back of the
room all the way to the stage walked up
the stairs out of that wheelchair on his
own I asked him he said I just I just
have to work on staying in this
emotional state because the longer I
stay there the more I'm noticing that my
body's responding he's not saying why am
I why am I not healed he understands
that the only way he can actually heal
is to change him right and so now it
becomes very practical right because
it's very practical I think it's
important that practical part of it I
think sometimes people think they're
disqualified if they can't explain
something they do well let me tell you
one of the interesting things on the
show many of the people that do things
exceptionally well that have been on my
show athletes or entertainers
really don't do a very good job of
explaining it yeah they embody it and I
think sometimes someone listens to
somebody like you who can explain this
and think that they're disqualified from
becoming good if they can't explain how
they're doing it but the truth is it's a
repeated experience that becomes
familiar for them without the need to
express how they're doing it right right
and for me right this is your this is
your life is teaching people to do this
and giving them the tools but for the
vast majority of people it's it's
creating the experience a lot of
everybody everybody
has done this at least once in their
life what did they did they sat down and
they said what would it be like to be
happy what would it be like to be
healthy what would it be like to have a
new life what do we like to be in love
and they ask the question instead of
getting on their cell phone and texting
someone or posting they actually sat
there and they actually said let me
answer the question yeah let me get
uncomfortable here and what is it that I
truly want what would I have to change
about myself to be healthy to be happy
to be well successful what are my bad
habits they get busy writing down
all the the the choices they want to
make all the things they want to do they
start writing down all their goals all
their experiences and every goal or
experience they write down in their
future there's an emotion they get
inspired they get optimistic they get
grateful they get energized and those
emotions fuel more thoughts and now
they're they're they're actually
changing their biology and then they do
something really really really really
really important
they start looking at the thoughts that
they no longer want to think they write
them down I can't it's too hard I'll
start tomorrow I don't feel good until
they start looking at the choices
they're going to have to stop making and
when they they understand when they stop
making those choices it's going to be
uncomfortable that's the hardest part
about change they start thinking about
the things they have to stop doing I
gotta get off the couch I got to stop
watching this I gotta stop over reading
whatever it is and then we've all done
this
and there comes a moment where you start
noticing that like you start saying hey
I believe this is this is actually going
to happen right and that's when you take
the foot off the gas pedal and you start
really realizing wow I was the resource
of actually making this happen and that
I changed yeah I changed in the process
so
the the exciting part about it you tell
people who created wealth who talk to
people who created relationships that
are talk to people who have created
Health they'll tell you my disease
my poverty was my greatest teacher my
past was my greatest teacher they looked
back at their past and now there's no
longer an emotion associated with it the
memory without the emotional charges
wisdom now you get to go to the Future
you get to create whatever your free
willed you you could be anybody you want
to be in the process I think you know
one of the most important things is it's
so much easier to forget this
information than to remember even me you
know I have to say to myself okay Joe
dispenza what do you know and take a
moment and just set down my cell phone
and disconnect from everything and
really have a thought like
and keep reconstructing the model in my
mind it's so important to do that
because if we understand the what and
the why and the how it gets easier then
we assign more meaning and more belief
and more intention behind it and
and if you have to say okay
okay if I'm living by these emotions
that are familiar to me and I'm
signaling the same genes in the same way
okay now I have to be conscious of not
feeling that way and you have to make a
different choice and the hardest part
about changes stop making the same
choices you did the day before because
the moment
you decide to do something differently
and make a new Choice it's going to be
uncomfortable you're going to leave the
known familiar world of the familiar
emotions and thoughts and behaviors
the body is the unconscious mind is
going to want to return back to what it
knows because we trained it that way so
it's a retraining process so if the
person says okay if I can marry a clear
intention I gotta work on getting my
brain more coherent okay they got that
in the formula that'll be a good signal
out if I could slow my brain waves down
I can learn how to do that I can get
beyond my thinking I'm a little combined
I can enter the operating system of my
autonomic nervous system program that
okay if I can combine it with an
elevated emotion really practice trading
that that suffering or that pain for
something else yeah it may take me a
little bit to feel that emotion but I
think if I keep working at it I'll begin
to change my emotional state when I feel
that emotional state I'm not going to be
thinking about the past I'm going to be
thinking about the future so so the
thought and the feeling the stimulus in
response the image and the emotion is
conditioning the body emotionally into
the future so the person says okay he
said or I read or someone else said the
environment signals the gene okay let me
write that down environment signals the
gene okay I gotta remember that
the end product of an experience in the
environment is the emotion okay
um if I'm feeling gratitude
and gratitude's emotional signature
means I've just received something
favorable or something wonderful just
happened to me
if I can feel the emotion of gratitude
before the event occurs
then my body would be so objective that
it's living in that future I would begin
to change my gene expression and the
stronger the emotion I feel the more I'm
going to pay attention to the picture in
my mind that I'm going to be remembering
my future my brain and body are going to
look like the event has already occurred
before it happened and if genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of my
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life
then I'm going to keep signaling these
I'm going to keep knocking on the door
every day and I don't care if my life is
falling apart I'm not going to fall to
that familiar emotion I'm not going to
speak the same way I'm not going to
think the same way what thoughts do I
want to fire and wire in my brain and
with intention and attention I'm going
to keep reviewing them till it becomes
an automatic thought in my head like you
can
what how am I going to be today how am I
going to be with my family I'm going to
be in traffic I'm going to be with my
co-workers how am I going to be when I'm
alone
and you start rehearsing who you're
going to be the brain in the present
moment doesn't know the difference
between the outer world or the inner
world it's the brain what it's imagining
looks real and if we're present
the brain looks like you already did it
you're priming the brain it's no longer
on record of the past now you're it's a
map to the Future you're you're in place
keep practicing that rehearsal in your
mind it's going to become automatic and
you're going to start behaving like that
person then you said
can I teach my body emotionally what
this future feels like before it happens
if you could truly open your heart and
truly feel that elevated emotion if you
kept practicing that I promise you you
would feel more of that in your day and
less of the other place and meditation
means to become familiar with and how
you think how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality that's the
game right so when that occurs then it's
no longer about
the past and what happened to you and
the story people tell about that they're
telling a story of their future in fact
they're more in love with their future
than they are with their past
they believe in the future more than
they believe in their past and and I
think that when we believe in ourselves
we believe in possibilities and we
believe in possibilities we have to
believe in ourselves and showing up
every day
means you must believe it's true when
you stop showing up then you don't
believe it's true any longer and and
enough people that have that kind of
conviction literally step into a new
body they step into a new a new life
they step into a new future and I I hope
um but that becomes the new normal
um and and you know research says that
Collective networks of observers
determine reality that's the latest
uh so we just got to make sure enough of
us are observing a different reality
from an elevated place of Union and
connection instead of Separation that's
that divides communities because of
survival and stress and that's a great
way to create polarity in the world and
the union of polarity takes place in the
heart and that's where it starts it
doesn't end there it just starts there
and when I see the heart and forming the
brain I saw two students that we grabbed
one was chasing a little child around a
one and a half year old child and he was
being challenged and the other guy was
working and Staffing and running around
and we got him in the chair and we said
okay let's let's get some brain the
heart coherence and you know we had 15
20 minutes to do with these guys and you
saw them way out of balance right it's
just way out of bounds and all of a
sudden here comes that low frequency in
the heart boom like a big drum boom
boom all of a sudden we see that low
frequency the energy in the heart that's
only indigenous to the heart itself
starts rising and then all of a sudden
you see it rising and you see the
sympathetic nervous system rise with it
so now we know they're totally relaxed
and they're totally awake and aware the
sympathetic nervous isn't working for an
arousal when you see that kind of
connection and you see someone be able
to change that
a matter of moments my eyes say they
should be able to do that with their
eyes open at any moment it should be
such a skill and that's that's when we
we maintain our energy and our power you
can't go to the Future holding on to the
biology of your past decide what
thoughts you can bring to your future
write them down thoughts like I can't
it's too hard I'll never change I'll
start tomorrow what's wrong with me it's
someone else's fault
decide on what behaviors or actions or
unconscious habits you have to change
how do you talk do you complain do you
blame do you make excuses do you feel
sorry for yourself it just becomes so
conscious of those behaviors that you'll
never go unconscious again and lastly
you have to decide what emotions no
longer belong in your future that means
if you want to be wealthy you can take
lack if you want to be healthy you can't
take insecurity or fear you got to begin
to condition your body to a new mind if
you do this
every single day your personality
creates your personal reality and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel change any
one of those things and you change your
life and begin to measure the effects of
you it costs give it a shot people that
were traumatized from childhood that
were abused sexually physically
emotionally that were suicidal that had
all kinds of health conditions they came
to the edge of that emotion that kept
them connected to the past and they were
ready to give up in one meditation
because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
they thought about all the times for the
last year that they never missed a day
of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or when they wanted
to quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times that they went to that
point and they went one more time really
and their words are always the same and
my heart blew wide open and I look back
at my entire past and I don't want to
change one thing in my past because it
brought me to this present moment and I
can see my betrayers I could see the
people in my life uh that had a hand in
this and I have nothing but compassion
for them because now the person is no
longer viewing that past from the same
level of Consciousness they're viewing
it from a place of Love of wholeness and
they see the greater good of all of it
and now
their conditions their health conditions
their endometriosis their uterine tumors
I mean whatever it is literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal why would they be they're free
so it can happen in an instant when the
heart is healed and everybody gets the
new signal the body's out of the past
the body's no longer feeling the
emotions of the past and sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
our immune system is kind of like our
rudimentary nervous system it has cells
that are mobile and they're called
plasma cells or white blood cells and
their job is an internal defense in many
of our bodies plasma cells uh line the
mucous membranes got the digestive tract
uh all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense against
foreign Invaders and toxins and when the
immune system is facing some foreign
Invader whether it be a virus a bacteria
a mold a fungus some foreign agent it is
the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger and begin to attack
these foreign agents and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells and T cells are like the
ninjas of the immune system they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
Invader and T cells have these little
trumpets that stick out on the receptor
site so picture this big circular
spherical glob and you have all these
different receptors and these T cell
receptors are these long trumpet
appendages and when they come up to a
virus or they come up to a bacteria when
they come up to even a cancer cell
they notice that is a foreign agent and
immediately this T Cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin the cause that are
an agent to to die and then memorizes
that foreign agent and passes the
information onto the army of the rest of
the white blood cells in the body and
and this is a strong immune system and
when plasma cells and white blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y and those
y-shaped proteins are antibodies and
what they do is when the the white blood
cell releases an antibody it begins to
block The receptors of the foreign agent
that's trying to attack the white blood
cells so when a healthy immunoglobulin
is released it suppresses the the
Warfare uh the the cell receptors that
are trying to attack the white blood
cell and now you have a strong defense
you have a strong immune system and at
your body right now is doing that in
fact your body is always evaluating all
those foreign agents whether it's a
virus a bacteria or even a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance in the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness the new model of reality
is about causing an effect
that means then you have to feel
gratitude every day for your new
experience to occur
you can't wait for your success to feel
empowered
you have to be empowered to create the
success
and when you teach people how to do this
and they move into a new state of being
they begin to create the life that they
want
how many people are still with me
but to the materialists they would say
well no
no no no I'm going to wait for my money
to come and then I'm going to give
thanks
and those people pretty much are living
by the emotions of the past
and if you're living by the emotions of
the past you were viewing your future
through the lens of the past and your
vision will fade
because when you bring up an elevated
emotion you will see the vision clearly
and leaders in history that change the
world knew how to change a culture look
at Martin Luther King
he talked about Justice and then got
enough people inspired that they felt
empowered enough to do something about
it
people came out of their resting state
and so then you share the same brain as
Martin Luther King
and being defined by a vision of the
future begins to change a culture
but most people have the same thoughts
or the same intentions and they live by
the same familiar emotions and for the
most part they're in their past the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt or
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes a resource of
light and information and we're turning
it into chemistry and we're literally
robbing the body's energy right so so
then living like that for the short term
is okay because the body can move back
to homeostasis and then restore itself
but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limbic
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide so the
future then is created by a clear
intention and an elevated emotion now
listen closely
that you have to cultivate in your inner
environment of thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them
and getting a person beyond the old self
then is the great work that's what we're
here for
so
we've studied motivation
and I can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people is what's called
purpose motivation Duty motivation or
Mission motivation you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you to instill change
in the world look at Elon Musk how many
people know who he is
Elon Musk he created Tesla Motors
you know him you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from 0 to 60 in less than
five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that you know crawled along the road
and he said I'm going to do this I don't
know how I'm going to do it but I have a
vision
and I'm going to get the best engineers
in the world and instead of creating a
new product and selling it to a
corporation
I'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me I'm going to
change the world by changing our
Reliance on oil
and I am going to make a difference in
the world and I am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now Motor Trend Magazine never
raided a car up close to a hundred
they rated the Tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of it if you think about
the illusion of three-dimensional
reality and and this hologram that were
fooled into our senses into this concept
of Separation there's me here and
there's you there and there's distance
in space and there's objects and there's
things in this three-dimensional reality
causes us to go from one point of
awareness I'm here to another point of
awareness uh say the front door and we
have to move through space and we move
through space it takes time right so
anything that we want in our lives takes
time and energy got to go to work
and you gotta you know you gotta do all
the things and then you got to save
money and then you go buy the thing and
that's the rules of three-dimensional
reality the plane of demonstration means
you got to do something right so then
there's me here and then my dreams are
way way out there and I estimate how
long it's going to take for me to arrive
at those streams because we're playing
by the rules of three-dimensional
reality and we play by those rules
um
for the most part I'm gonna wait for the
experience to occur in order to have the
experience producing emotion and the
emotion is the chemical feedback as a
result of the event now there's nothing
wrong with this that's the game in in
three-dimensional world
if you're going to shorten the distance
between cause and effect between the
thought of something and the experience
of something you got to go to a
different set of rules and you have to
create from the quantum field now the
quantum field is an invisible field of
energy that exists Beyond this space and
time now this takes a little bit of
imagination because
if we don't have any space between us
then we're connected there's no
separation uh and and there's no time so
now when you go to the realm of a
Quantum the rules change because in the
quantum things are connected energy
connects things together
so then if you are able to create from
the field instead of from matter and
it's not matter that's emitting a field
it's the field that's actually creating
matter if we could change information in
the field we could change the Hologram
in three-dimensional reality and it
turns out you only need two things to do
that
in a super coherent brain super
organized coherent brain and coherence
is a rhythm or an order so when the
brain is coherent it has a directive
it's an electrical charge it's the
signal we send out into the field we're
broadcasting information with our
thoughts
now most people who have been
conditioned and hypnotized into the
rules of three-dimensional reality
they're waiting for the experience to
happen to feel the emotion of the
experience to take away their lack or
separation like whatever it's abundance
it's love it's healing whatever it is
but in the quantum model
you have to combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion and that takes
heart coherence so we've done extensive
studies in training our community to
begin to feel the emotion of the event
before it happens and people say well I
don't know how it would feel because I
haven't experienced it well the answer
is really simple
if you felt gratitude or you felt
appreciation or love for life or a joy
for existence
and you combine that clear intention
with an elevated emotion the heart
produces a magnetic field and that
magnetic field expands out and it
transcends the rules of space and time
when you feel whole when you feel this
elevated emotion you feel connected you
feel bonded and so when you feel the
emotion of your future
you're connecting to the energy of the
future and your body is so objective
it does not know the difference between
the real life experience that's creating
that emotion and the emotion that you're
creating by thought alone the body's
actually believing it's living in that
future reality in the present moment so
if the thought sends the signal out and
the feeling draws the event back and
your brain and hard coherence you got a
really powerful Wi-Fi signal and when
you begin to do this properly you no
longer have to go anywhere to get
anything in other words you're not
living by the rules of of cause and
effect you're living by the rules of
causing an effect you're producing an
outcome now here's the cool part if
there's a vibrational match between your
energy and you've really refined that
signal
and you can synchronize your energy you
start having synchronicities in your
life and you start getting Universal
signs coming to you you have
opportunities you have synchronicities
serendipities coincidences and you're
not going anywhere to get it they're
coming to you now think about this if
you're connected to an invisible field
of energy that's the source of
everything physical and material if you
were Connected To Source why would you
go anywhere you wouldn't do that you
would say come to me right so so by
doing this properly
and causing an effect when you see
feedback in your life as the result of
what you're doing
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
now the cool part is is that once you
feel the excitement the inspiration The
Joy The Love For Life
that's actually reinforcing the feeling
that you've created with and if you
create again you refine the signal a bit
more you get more synchronicities no
more opportunities and the cool part
about our community
is that they're not saying oh God I have
to go create my life they're not saying
that they actually don't want to stop
doing it because they don't want those
they don't want the magic to end they
don't want those cool Quantum events
that are occurring in their life to stop
so it's not like I have to they're just
they're changing their energy and when
you change your energy you change your
life and I've been at this long enough
to tell you that nobody changes until
they change their energy and and and so
when you experiment with this as a as a
process and you learn a particular
formula and we've been we've been
refining this and studying it so much in
the last couple years
that the amount of coherence that we see
in some of our student Community is so
incredibly organized and not only
organized but the amount of energy in
the brain the amount of energy in the
heart is higher amplitude so no bigger
signal bigger Wi-Fi signal more
connection and so then you if you can
shorten the distance
between cause and effect
between the thought of what you want and
the experience of what you want
then you would start to master your life
and then you would start to see wow I
could actually if I if I could do this
what could I do next and and I'm happy
to say that you know people are doing it
pretty well if you could give everyone
in the world an experiment to do for 30
days one activity that they'd have to do
every day for 30 days what would it be
oh I would ask them to take out a piece
of paper and write down every thought
that they've been thinking that standing
in the way between their future and and
where they are to write down every habit
or behavior even how they speak that
stops them from becoming the person that
is healthy wealthy or free and then to
begin to
recognize the emotions that keep them in
the same state of being every single day
and become so conscious of those
thoughts behaviors and emotions that
they wouldn't let any of them slip by
unnoticed by them then I would have them
write down the thoughts they do want to
fire certain wire in their brain I would
have them write down what the behaviors
look like of a great person that they
wanted to become and I would have them
practice thinking about it and practice
rehearsing it and then I would say to
them what emotions would you feel when
your future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who do
you do want to be you should begin to
see evidence in your life and when it
comes in a way that you least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more of the
creators of our lives and less of the
victims of our lives and then if you
said well listen I'm not going to wait
for my healing
to feel gratitude I'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
I'm gonna actually teach my body
emotionally what that future feels like
before it happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer World to Change our inner world
right
waiting is not creating I mean period
And when people they could have the
greatest intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then when we're in separation in lack
waiting for our wealth to feel abundance
we're basically living our whole life in
pain right so then if you reason this
and a person can get up from their
meditation and they literally feel
differently and they're feeling the
emotions of their future before it
happens this is turning the the whole
process around
they can't be looking for it why would
they be looking for it if they felt like
it there it already happened now there's
no separation now this is when those
serendipities and coincidences and
opportunities begin to show up in
people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they start believing
they're more of the creator of their
life yeah and less of the victim of
their life with a community of
like-minded like like antler similar
energy of people uh everybody
understands they get one another you
know you you communities tends to be the
thing now that in terms of our social
media and the feedback we're getting
everybody wants more Community because
you get a you get a thousand people in
an audience and they're energy
synchronized now you're looking at
something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this I just talked to a
researcher yesterday we're going to
measure a thousand people when they
reach that synchronized moment when
they're we can we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a Ambience
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering co-mingling with the
persons next to you when that energy
starts to synchronize it's going to
produce a bigger wave the higher the
amplitude the higher the wave the more
energy there is so now you have one mind
and one heart and now when it comes to
Healing others and we've done the
research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field that's that
that has to be changed so once people
start reversing this then you start
seeing tumors disappearing you start
seeing blind people seeing deaf people
hearing you start seeing people with
Parkinson's disease switch on I mean you
start seeing
stage four cancer is reversing because
now they're you're you're you're
swimming Upstream you're going to the
headwaters and making that change let's
demystify meditation because it has so
many stigmas around it close your eyes
Retreat from your life disconnect from
your body disconnect from your
environment disconnect from your
schedule and just give yourself an hour
or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because when
you invest in yourself you invest in
your future and when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
and when you believe in possibilities
you believe in yourself and if you don't
believe in possibilities then you don't
believe in yourself and you don't
believe in yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming The New Normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make to
connect is is amazing because that which
we are seeking is seeking us it's not
like it is it matches our efforts and so
then when when people have that
uncompromising will the same way that
they go shopping for a dress or a pair
of earrings or go to the gym and work
out with the same intensity with the
same passion come up against themselves
and just say when the body's going given
everything it has it's when you say
that's all you got that's it that's all
you're going to put out to I'm ready and
so then
when you start overcoming that the side
effect of it is that all of a sudden
you're happy for no reason and you're
less seduced in believing that something
else you need something outside of it
outside of you to make you feel better
all of a sudden you're feeling better
every day without anything outside of
you and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that Ed guy he's different
different medications
but in actuality you're just Freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
Divine in us that that in essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful become more mindful become more
conscious we become more loving it's
it's its nature you know it just it just
it comes becomes who we are at the end
of the day if you really wanted to be
wealthy you say
how did I do today did I make the right
choices what was I ethical was I Purpose
Driven was I was I was I interested in
making a difference was I fair was I
tempered uh did I really think before I
spoke what what did I remember reading
about that book about that person that
did it how'd I do and if you said I when
did I fall from grace when did I lose it
okay I want that opportunity again I
want another shot at that and I'm going
in this way what would love do in this
situation what would greatness do and
now you you evolve your experience and
somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changes and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process if we're if we really learn and
we really get it but the trial and error
is so in important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and and they're ill because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and I would say the
same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am I not
healed you're still the old person
you're going to become that person every
day right turns out that when you sit
down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said God I I always
thought that this work really worked
that this these concepts are the truth
but I never believed it worked for me
and I was in a car accident in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief which overcame the belief and I
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities When You Believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and and
that's why people don't do the work I
mean if you you believe that your
thoughts created reality you would show
up every day and create and so a lot of
people believe in their past more than
they believe in their future a lot of
people fall in love are more in love
with their past or romance their past
instead of romance their future or love
their future it's it's that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can I open my heart how much more
can I Surrender into this infinite field
how much more can I become can I walk as
it with my eyes open people do
meditations and they have great
meditations me included and then you get
up you open your eyes and you're back in
the program and people want to know why
they haven't healed and we have
testimonies of people they're speaking
the truth they said my Ms my rheumatoid
and my lupus never went away
man great meditations I felt better
and then I realized with my eyes open I
was still that person and now next level
they're in the game and catching
themselves or catching how they speak
they're watching how they think they're
not letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing in now this is the this is the
great part and when a person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
Freedom that happens they look back at
their past they want to change one thing
in their past because it brought them to
that present moment that's the path no
longer existing that's the freedom so is
it worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
right that's what it's about right I
will never work in a relationship I just
won't if I'm working in a relationship
something's wrong I'll work on me and
I'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then I'm gonna step back and see
what is it about me not you what is it
about me that I need to really look at
and change now if there's a vibrational
match and it flows and it's fun and you
connect on
physically mentally Mind Body Soul you
know that's cool I think that's healthy
uh uh but a mission-driven person can't
be in a relationship where you have to
keep going back and and and trying to
fix something I just I just won't do
that I just think that when it when it's
right it's right and I'll know
yeah yeah so I think that I do think
that uh
relationships can be easy and I I do
think I I and I think that they should
be and I and I think that if you're
heart centered uh that's a different
place you meet uh than than uh other
emotions and and I and I and again every
time I have a mystical moment
and I feel that transcendental love that
I don't even know the word for uh every
time I have one of those moments I think
I got this all wrong it's just that it's
it is not chemical it's electric and you
got what all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we pres I mean we don't see things how
they are we see things how we are you
know and every inner experience that's
transcendental experience and riches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces emotion or energy in the body
so you start having transcendental
moments where you start connecting to
that field its signature is love I mean
but not love like a love for your puppy
it's this is like this is like an
arousal this is I don't know the other
word but spiritual arousal yeah and we
have the we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
I'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes and what do you mean just
watch she's gonna pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
Survival in the environment that
produces the reality this arouses is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss the arousal is
ecstasy the arousal is freedom but it's
it's not chemical it's it's you'll feel
it in every single cell in your body now
here's the outcome of that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
and broadens now because now you're
wired to perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so when you start having
moments where you hit that kind of
frequency or you have those moments of
love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness you're you're okay you can
love the person for their flaws because
you can see a part of yourself you used
to be that you no longer are and instead
of judgment you have compassion and you
can encourage and and and communicate
from a from a level of connection
instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
Works what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning well think
well first I would say what is the
greatest ideal of myself that I can be
today and I would not get up until I
felt like that person
the second thing I would say is can I
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if I do it properly then I will
be open to Opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing I would say is could I
sustain brain and heart coherence to the
point where that intelligence within me
that's giving me life begins to find a
door to open out so I can begin to see
evidence in my world what would you say
every evening before you go to sleep oh
yeah how did I do that how did I do how
did I do how did I do today I mean one
day one lifetime yeah how did I do today
did I change or help another human being
did I really change someone's future
future timeline lastly what is the
greatest thing I learned you think
60 to 70
000 thoughts in one day
out of those 60 to 70 000 thoughts that
you think in one day
90 of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before
so if you believe that your thoughts
somehow are connected to your life
then the same thoughts always lead to
the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions
and those very same emotions Drive the
very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry your
neurochemistry your neural hormones
and even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality
that's it
so then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
a new life
then you would have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it
you would have to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts and observe them
you would have to pay attention to your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you would have to look at the
emotions you live by every single day
that are connected to your past
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work
you literally have to become someone
else I believe in Free Will I would
never tell anybody what to believe like
politically or socially or whatever I I
want to provide them the tools and give
them the free will to create life
however they want and believe whatever
they want that's totally cool with me so
those people then
that want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed I mean and
it's not easy because it's re it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
that the Instinct and the unknown is
it's a Scary Place wow imagine not
having a body and we practice lingering
without a body in in in an infinite
space and without a name without a face
without a culture without a job without
a social security number without a
disease without a diet just as an
awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years of programming and
the people who actually overcome their
fear
and they traded for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger their genes
up regularly I mean there's just a host
of uh everything their brain changes
their heart rate variability they feel
differently and it's it's being measured
and and some of these people were
measuring this now in our events with
with reputable scientists in in
universities they're they're
shocked at what they're witnessing on a
cellular level on a brain level on a
heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body I it just was I
just got an email today of assign one of
our scientists said I ran this
three times
the virus that we exposed the cell to in
advance meditators does not enter the
cell it's outside the cell it won't a
virus in novice meditators some of it's
in the cell some of it sounds controls
all the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment there's
less of response that weakens them
they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large-scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is Bond
University a university in Australia on
the Gold Coast
senior researcher took the large
majority of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team was our community's
ability
to go to to get to that point where
they're nobody no one no thing nowhere
no time now I'm talking four seconds I'm
talking five seconds I'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
I know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get Beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your Material World
Turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into Alpha
and Theta you're suppressing the memory
bank of the known self that keeps you
plugged into three-dimensional reality
when you quiet down this mechanism
now all of a sudden you start connecting
to that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious Realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes here's the
deal with trauma and it's kind of an
interesting thing because when you're
traumatized some threat or some danger
or some condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world and the
quotient of change between the way you
normally feel and some alarm State when
you change your internal State and move
into that emergency mode you narrow your
focus on the cause and the Brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember we remember experience is
better because we can remember how they
feel and and that memory then changes
the person's biology so they think
neurologically within the circuits of
that experience and they feel chemically
within the boundaries of those emotions
and how we think and feel becomes our
state of being so so now the person
biologically is changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why because if the
environment signals the Gene and that's
the truth that's epigenetics and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion the emotion
that you feel from that event is
literally selecting the gene gosh it's
for you to begin to change and the genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain now it's in their body because
every time they think about that trauma
every time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective that it's believing it's
living in the same past experience 50 to
100 times a day and all you need is a
stimulus and response an image and an
emotion a thought and a feeling and
you're conditioning the body into the
past well you're conditioning the brain
body into the past what are the things
that
disturb or
disconnect our Awakening and connection
to the Divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times uh we have the
experience and we start to try and
because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
I've done that long enough and is
actually have to lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right so
that's one element I also think that our
response is emotionally like uh uh uh
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the Future like it
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
it doesn't work that way so then then
when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
I fail they didn't do it right no that's
all the program you show up again and
you go after it again
so familiar feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and and and we color reality
that way so
um I think I think familiar emotions uh
get in the way as well and then of
course there's always belief and a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and it's called the memory the
moment they draw a conclusion about that
experience they'll think neurologically
within those circuits and they'll feel
chemically within the boundaries of
emotion thinking and feeling thinking
and feeling belief becomes an
unconscious or subconscious state of
being they don't most people don't even
know they have beliefs about things
about God about relationships about
money because it's it's not a conscious
thing it's a subconscious thing yeah so
in order to change a belief or a
perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in it's not like you
go 50 in you got to go all in you got to
make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say I remember the
moment
I made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge Stone you drop in the
quantum field Big Splash big waves your
brain is organized to reflect everything
you know in your life
your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
Shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails and
hurry up and check your Facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions living by the same
emotions but secretly expecting your
life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says nerve cells that
fire together wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices demonstrating
the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way those circuits
begin to become more connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits automatic emotional
reactions beliefs and perceptions and
even attitudes that function just like a
computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again the repetition of those
actions over time conditions your body
to know how to do it well better than
your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind where you've done
something so many times that the body
now knows how to do it better than the
brain
and so 95 of most people's behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs emotional
reactions or subconscious programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new Connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of Consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the Nobel Prize Laureate candel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of Connections
in their brain from thirteen hundred
connections to 2600 connections
but if they didn't review that
information if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned the part in hours or
days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections then remembering is
maintaining and sustaining those
connections your body rejects viruses
all the time of course it has memorized
certain viruses that you've been exposed
to it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses it's not every virus wins
in the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has quite a library of
memories in the in the in the white
blood cells so your body is fighting
viruses and bacteria all the time
there's a constant competition going on
really so our research shows that four
days
of opening your heart releases
immunoglobulin a your body's primary
defense against bacteria and viruses
it's better than the flu shot it's the
body's natural flu shot and that's the
innate intelligence of body saying I got
this I got a lot of energy in fact I got
a surplus of energy in fact I'm
radiating energy and now there's not too
much out of the world it will now my
outer world is not controlling my inner
world my inner world now is functioning
independent of what's going on in my
outer world and now you're manifesting
you're manifesting ah now you got it now
you're in a creative state because
people are coming to you yes right
exactly now you're a magnet now you have
a field right and you have energy to
heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light in
information cells are getting new
information that that are causing uh um
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so so that immunoglobulin a in
four days went up 50 percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then causes another chemical to activate
the arteries in your heart to swell and
now just like when energy moves into
your sexual organs and it swells of
blood and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart and
now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel you feel an incredible amount
of Love yeah you feel you feel you feel
whole and now the more whole you feel
our research shows then the less
separate you feel from the things you
want in your life because you feel like
you already have them you only want
things when you're in lack but when you
feel whole then it feels like it's
already happened and that tends to be
the exact emotion that causes those
synchronicities and serendipities and
coincidences to happen in our life and
you say to a person what are you doing
and they're saying I'm not doing
anything I'm I'm just loving life I'm
being myself I'm free I'm free from the
past I'm free from my story of the past
time in fact I'm more connected to the
energy of my future than I am to the
energy of my past why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy I really think that
when the survival Gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have 10 really
great things happen in our one thing bad
and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival genes activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because you don't want it to happen
again so what people do when they're
aroused is they start thinking it's
going to happen so they actually select
the worst
case scenario in their mind
and then emotionally Embrace that future
before it happens and they're
conditioning their body it's become the
mind of anxiety and fear so in
preservation and in survival if you
prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
Balance but when there's an arousal
arousals there's three things that
create arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
High beta and most people need something
or someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal State and the
moment they notice a change in their
Eternal safe and they pay attention to
what's causing it they start developing
a dependency on it right so
turns out that when we teach people how
to self-regulate and change their brain
waves we could actually see then that
the incoherence that disorderliness
that's taking place in the brain you
know when you're over aroused you're
overly analytical and you're shifting
your attention from one problem to one
person to one thing to one place to
another problem to another circumstance
to your phone to your car and each one
of those elements has a neurological
Network in the brain so the arousal
causes these different circuits to fire
out of order and the brain is incoherent
so take two waves that are out of phase
and mix them when they interfere they
flatten out there's no energy so energy
leaves the brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there is something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline your
pupils dilate and your heart starts to
race and you're ready to run fight or
hide I mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker sitting
right next to you or six feet away and
and you're judging them you're the same
arousals they can play so what's once
very adaptive becomes very maladaptive
this is where it gets challenging so
when we teach people how to open their
focus we've done thousands and thousands
of brain scans and they get beyond their
analytical processes and they open their
awareness and go from a conversion Focus
to a divert and focus and they learn how
to relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into Alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brain waves move into
Theta we we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is
sleeping but the mind is awake and now
the door between the conscious mind and
the subconscious mind is wide open and
if they can regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and Gamma is super Consciousness
now I'm not talking about
a little gamma I'm not talking about a
lot of gamma I'm not talking about a
really loud camera I'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
so there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this that could be Alpha
right Theta would be
and if everybody could do this it's
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this it would be really hard for all of
us to do that at the same time so it
takes a lot of order a lot of awareness
a lot of energy to be able to create
that kind of order so
that's how fast the brain is in that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy that
arousal is bliss it is the most familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
and that memory then that the person has
that is so profoundly different than the
feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner State and with that
experience comes a very lucid picture a
very profound Insight a download of
information
that's the moment then the body many
times rewrites the biological program
energy
is informing matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember diseases
autonomic dysregulation now it's getting
into a very very high frequency of order
and it's sending very coherent
information to the cells and tissues
sending energy to the cells and tissues
and cells begin to emit more coherent
light and information and then there's
the disease
and there it's not you asked if is it
possible then can that people can heal
that quickly in one week yeah because
what if they create an inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or Joy or Freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past and when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion the stronger the emotion you
feel from that breakthrough the more
you're going to pay attention to the
image in your mind and now you're now
beginning to brand new circuitry in the
brain and your body's being conditioned
into a new future and the stronger the
emotion you feel the more you pay
attention to the picture the more you're
conditioning the body over time to the
Future instead of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally then that emotion ultimately
signals a new Gene that up regulates
that genes produce better proteins and
the person and all of a sudden starts
healing and we have researched to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells wow
to Signal stem cells to to suppress
um uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you come with a lot of
genes and they're just a library of
potentials they're just a storehouse of
information of possibilities so then you
got to get the right signal the right
lock into the key that begins to select
and instruct genes that cause genes to
make different proteins and you can
regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that structure
that's function that's harm
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth when you hit Pay Dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the Divine
whatever you want to call it when your
Consciousness merges with a greater
Consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy Bliss Oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the Wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car or whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then that is what I'm
after because when you have those
transcendental moments and you
understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry and the praying
that's what experience does and the
experience produces a feeling but it's
not chemical it's electric and it's
orderly and every cell of your body is
jiggling in an order and they're and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs
your spectrum of reality is going to
broaden some conditioning some illusion
something is removed and you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival now you start
seeing patterns and lights and
information
that are Transcendent of
three-dimensional reality in your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry is there
and now your your experience of the
world changes you get an upgrade to the
to the VR set the virtual reality side
oh you got the upgrade you got 2.0 and
now it looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different in
the world look you're seeing Beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together I mean that's the
blessing of an Awakening right that's
where that's where we're going what do
you think the world Humanities challenge
will be over the next decade as we enter
2020.
um back to the principle Louis of just
different paradigms beginning to
collapse you know economically
politically socially environmentally
religiously the education journalism the
uh you know medicine
um they they have to uh move into chaos
and chaos is just unpredictable not
working yeah exactly but now here's the
challenge for Humanity you have one of
two ways to embrace the breakdown of
those those paradigms you can face them
with anger and hostility and fear and
you are only contributing to more of it
we have to see that those breakdowns are
essential for something greater to
happen now
we can't wait
for governments to take care of us
that's we can't wait for uh medicine to
to give us a drug that's going to heal
us from a condition
the truth is with a greater level of
consciousness
the change in Awareness because of
information
the greatest challenge we have is those
as those paradigms break down is to no
longer emotionally react in the same way
and be victims you can't say this
President this person this this whatever
is actually making me feel this way and
think this way basically you're in the
program that you're something outside of
you is controlling you how you feel and
how you think so then to self-regulate
then is to say how I think and feel was
going to change my outer environment so
then we're all faced with great
opportunities brilliantly disguised as
impossible situations and we are at that
point at that Nexus point in our
Evolution as a species so then you don't
try to fix that that's never going to
work what you do is you create something
better and then everybody just naturally
just leaves that and goes here now it
used to be some people would just come
here and the majority would stay here
because they're clinging to what they've
been programmed or believing but now
because of information everybody's like
that's not gonna work I already know
it's not going to work and I don't care
what anybody says this is working for me
so
people are moving to new to new um to
new applications to new paradigms
because it's working for them so as long
as we don't emotionally react to the
breakdown that's happening currently in
the world and chaos is just
unpredictable order you know as as as
things move towards disorder the novelty
that's being created is literally chaos
because the known and everything's
staying the same is order but as you
step out into that unknown it's then
you're having the chaos is unpredictable
order being expressed through novelty
and we have to be able to learn how to
take that disorder and with the
application of brain and heart coherence
create more order so you can't just say
hey I'm standing up for peace and you
know and being being miserable with your
co-worker you you you don't get to talk
about peace until there's you you are
the you're the Living Prayer of Peace
not just we know we know crime rates go
down and
violence goes down when there's peace
projects in communities where there's
meditation on peace but when those peace
Gathering projects end you know you see
that crime and violence and everything
returns back to the same level so it's
not enough to just think it we got to
demonstrate it so if I'm demonstrating
peace and you're demonstrating peace
somebody else because of mere neurons is
going to go wow that person's
unpredictable wow they're different it's
given me permission to do the same
so I think that ultimately moving into
that state of being you know as human
beings and and and creating Unity that
you know you keep watching so many
programs on television that talk you
into Prejudice that talk you into
separation that talk you into fear that
talk you into violence that talk you
into war deceit negativity
um you're you're not going to trust
anybody in fact you're going to see
difference between you and me or anybody
because that's what separation does but
when you're heart centered and you feel
connected you don't see the person any
longer right you see something
transcending them you see in essence
right and I think if you do that really
well
that kind of emergence of a of a new
consciousness
but that's less dependent on on all of
those outer things is really difficult
to control and if you want to control a
community control their emotions and
control them in survival when you
overcome your emotions you can see the
hidden meaning behind all things and
when everybody's looking this way you
may be looking that way because you
understand look you've just overcome
your fear you've just overcome your
hostility and anger you've overcome the
program of whatever it is I swear to you
you're going to be able to connect
people and that that then is the hope of
the future I think that if we share the
same experiences because we like the
same things we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions I can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information
and if we share the same energy energy
is information so many people as an
example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so I
suffer more than you than you say I you
I suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're someone who's has a uh
accountability partner that that you
exchange ideas like this with and it's a
different frequency a different energy
so when energy comes together as
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and then you
feel an elevation if there's dissonance
then your your sensing meter is how you
feel about that person many times in
your gut or in your heart or wherever
and there's Decon there's uh destructive
interference and there's no energy
involved so I think that's just a
practice but really the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such a resonance
such coherence that when you walk in the
room that you raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition and that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model that
we use so imagine 1500 people in an
event where everybody's getting super
coherent and the interference that's
going on in the room is creating these
high amplitudes now we've measured that
in the room and the energy in the room
is
off the chart many times there's I mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude Freedom Bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency so but it turns out
you could have a collective group of
people with a lot of energy and being
coherent and it creates entropy yeah you
could have a smaller group of people
that are highly coherent and put out a
very big signal so when we see a
collective really get coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that I would I would
never expect I mean I I don't I don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's Divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
I think our I think our truth meter is
really whether we feel it lifted uh or
we feel like we've been robbed if you're
alive in this world and you haven't been
experiencing the quickening I mean I
mean you know I said to uh someone the
other day
the day where you end your day and Feel
Complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that and you know
there's always more emails and more
things to chat right so the demand has
has has
pressed us into this crazy realm of of
uh of of
um multi-tasking and I think that you
start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news your
cell phone your computer and you start
going this way
I think it's uh into the present moment
than where you place your attention is
where you place your energy and you're
truly in the present moment you got a
lot of energy to execute you got to let
out energy to use and you want to be
able to do that eyes open the more
scattered your energy the less you have
to focus on pushing one thing forward
that's why people's dreams don't happen
because they're scattered there's no
look look if you keep putting your
attention on some future experience that
you are imagining with your mind your
body is going to follow your mind right
there because that's where your energy
is but if you're putting your attention
on everything known in your life the
shower the coffee maker you know the
toilet and your body's following your
mind every day to the known but we want
your body to follow your mind to the
unknown right enough people get to doing
that and you could do better in creating
things in your life that we see this
wealthy people in our work that have
focused on wealth some of them living in
the back seat of their car some of them
bankrupt that now have multi-million
dollar companies what do you think they
want to do with that money
they want to give it away yeah get back
let me tell you why not because of any
other reason is that they now know that
they create more right well why why if
you're abundant why abundance to me has
changed abundance means I have more than
I need like way more than I need so if I
have way more than I need and I know how
to create it
then take it I'll create more of it so
now you're no longer holding on in
scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and I think
that that's how we're innately wired I
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another we shine for one another not to
outshine another person to shine to show
them if they can shine and that's that
to me is super healthy so then I'm I'm
applauding your success because I want
you to succeed because you're telling me
that if you can do it I can do it so so
there's no longer any separation I think
that's hopeful for the world then you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me I
wanna I wanna study you because I want
to bring that into who I'm becoming and
you create a strong community that way
if you are not
fine by some vision
that is bigger than
bigger and you are not passionate about
that Vision then you're left with the
old Hardware of the past in your brain
and you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions and those new emotions should
drive new thoughts and that's called
evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future ask yourself at the end of your
day I do this every day how'd I do how'd
I do today bro how'd you do just do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it that caused you to go
unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm going to plan my behaviors and the
act of closing your eyes and rehearsing
what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software Pro program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I'm just gonna need a minute it takes
some breaths they get back in they
connect to the energy of their future
this is incidental compared to where
they're going so they don't fall from
grace they don't allow their energy to
drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and I don't feel
like doing the work well that's the time
they get back on the horse yeah because
because it's the it's all of those times
that we self-correct those are the most
valuable moments thus people who have
had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's Evolution so
important in that of the infinite places
you can put your attention
let's put it on your heart now when you
place your attention is where you place
your energy why because we want this
Center to bloom fourteen hundred
thirteen hundred different chemicals
that restoring regenerate the body let's
breathe let's open this up let's
practice this let's start learn how to
lead with our heart a different
Consciousness yeah in the beginning
it's a little difficult but you stay
with it and you practice it pedal by
pedal by pedal placing your attention
there you're putting your own life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love Inward and the body will start
responding and in a week's time if we're
doing that three times a day or over and
over again
sooner or later that thing is going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood this Center when you
start feeling love you make a chemical
called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals the chemical called
derived endothelial relaxing Factor you
know what that is it causes the arteries
in your heart to literally open up so
your heart is going to be filled with
blood and oxygen and nutrients it's
physiological it's going to feel full
you're going to have a hard on
your heart is going to heal right and
when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over I mean it is and people
are in they're sobbing because they
realize that this this Center finally
like a child I think we're all faced
with great opportunities brilliantly
disguised as impossible situations and
in order like for me personally and I
and after looking through your book and
reading a good portion of it I mean for
me there's there's no school of ancient
wisdom that you need to go to be
initiated your life is your initiation
if you're paying attention so we meet
challenges in our life from a certain
level of mind right a certain level of
Consciousness or unconsciousness and
even Einstein said we have to go to a
greater level of consciousness
uh then the Consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before so we could we
confront problems or challenges in our
life and as a side note I was having
breakfast with a researcher just last
week who's studying what happens when we
perceive and condition in our
environment as a problem how it weakens
the organism they're measuring this and
when a person sees it as a challenge how
they draw energy they raise the energy
of their body back into order
so if we said I want to be
wealthy or I want to be healthy
well what what you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're gonna have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that I am feeling about that
circumstance and that feeling is causing
me to think about it so you say oh it's
impossible they'll never change I'll
hire a hit man I'll hire the mafia I'll
hire an attorney I'll hit my friend's
friend to talk to him and nothing
changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcasts
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge what piece of
information what would love do what
would greatness look like okay I don't
know all right well certainly somebody
in history has faced this problem
don't get on Facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get go
look it up and study and read and learn
you'll own it and you'll say wow that
person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times well hell I had
the wrong view of wealth okay then
failure is not a thing I got to overcome
failure well yep just climb the step
yeah okay I'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts I'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field if I were facing that circumstance
and situation again with that person
that circumstance what do I learn from
that circumstance how could I do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
Consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious now
there's wisdom and wisdom is the memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that that what now now you don't
create your reality you only create your
reality when things are good no well
somehow you got to Tango through this
somehow your objectivity in not reacting
emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation to me
Consciousness is awareness awareness is
paying attention and noticing and so 95
of Who We Are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hard-wired thoughts that that you
think every day that it just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we have that day like
how does someone become aware you don't
have to do that you just have to sit
down close your eyes and not move and
then you'll get you'll you'll start
seeing what am I thinking about right
now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the Consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program thinking about the thinking yeah
who's doing the thinking of the thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act becomes so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you gotta say oh my God
this feeling that I've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
I didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me and all of a sudden
as you start becoming conscious of it
you're beginning to objectify your
subjective self you're you're pulling
out of those programs and nobody likes
to do that because it's uncomfortable
they'd rather turn on their cell phone
start texting get on the internet you
know watch TV to distract them from that
moment and that is what they have to
move through in order to get to their to
their own personal freedom so the first
step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you won't go unconscious to any thought
any Behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness stay conscious
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you got it
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh I mean how many times have I
done it thousands but I'm not gonna give
up because the moments in which I do
connect or the moments that I do have
that transcendental experience
what matters the most after it when I
have that transcendental moment I look
back
and all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
I'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further or you had a rough day
and you just went in and you just you at
the end of the day you surrender and you
have the classic Oh My God moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
um you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
um staying conscious and staying where
and staying present is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this this intelligence that
lives within you and I that's governing
everything material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it as well as you can get
present with anything else and just
because you can't see it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist right and that that that
realm you can't experience with your
senses you can only experience with your
awareness so then people have to take
their attention off their bodies and go
from a somebody to a nobody take their
attention off the people in their life
and go from that they identify with and
go from a someone to a no one take their
attention off the things in their life
their cell phone their computer their
car and go from something to nothing
take their attention off where they
sleep where they work where they're
sitting and go from somewhere to Nowhere
take their attention off the predictable
future and the familiar past and time
and go from some time to no time and now
if you're taking all of your attention
off of everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
Consciousness and now that is the bridge
that is the door to the quantum field
and you can't enter the quantum field as
a somebody so if someone has spent their
whole life working on having the perfect
body or so much so they have so much
attention on their pain where you place
your attentions where you place your
energy it's going to take some work for
them to take all of their attention off
their body right because they'll go
they'll do it and then they'll go back
let's see if the Pain's still there oh
the Pain's still there so it's a little
bit of a waltz in the beginning but as
people start applying this you start
getting better at it meditation the
actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation if people
are really really believing that their
astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well you've seen
three 236 on the clock and 4 18 on the
clock but you're looking for 11 11. well
then that's your reality because that's
where your attention is right so I don't
subscribe to that but I respect that
because that person is going to keep
that belief until it no longer serves
them and they're either going to evolve
their belief or they're not and if they
don't so be it but if they do they're
going to realize sooner or later it's
not working for them I have certain
beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical world
and one foot in the Mysterious World
because I can't control all the events
that happen in my life but I can
certainly make choices that are going to
bring me closer to those experiences now
I also know from experience that when
I'm living by the hormones of stress and
I'm living in survival that you and I
and everybody else is always going to
try to control the outcome to try to
force the outcome to try to get in the
way try to analyze when it's going to
happen and how it's going to happen now
when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on to things we're deceitful
we're greedy because that's what those
chemicals do so we're always trying to
control and force the outcome because in
a sense we feel separate from something
greater we feel like we're matter trying
to change matter we feel like we're
we're vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means we have to go and get
it and and and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that you're a materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad at trying to change matter and soon
we're going to bump into each other and
there's going to be Sparks right so then
is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband for
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future The Familiar
past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the neural
circuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time till
finally the gene is programmed because
it took them 10 years to program the
gene for the disease it may take them a
few years to reprogram the gene now
we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival anger and
fear and guilt and shame the energy kind
of moves up a little bit we've measured
This Heart starts to open gets more
coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particles they're not afraid
of the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he's in like
the greatest part right now
ironic
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving them they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now they're no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past they're
no longer an identity that's connected
to a disease
they're no longer a body who's addicted
to an emotion they're no longer trying
to forecast the future based on the past
they're no longer a man they're no
longer a woman they're no longer a nurse
they're no longer black they're no
longer white they're no longer anything
they're they're they are completely
poised in the present moment and that
that present moment produces a
liberation of energy because the body is
no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent gets super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around their bodies enhanced we measure
that and the person could no longer
cares about the future of the past
they're happy in the present moment they
no longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free willed subject of
consciousness
but there's an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then and this is
where I I part from the spiritual
community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
that it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments
in the midst of that mystical experience
I have said in the midst of it I have
this all wrong I have said it right in
the midst of the experience I am doing
this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen
is giving up expectation which means you
have to surrender that belief how it's
going to happen or when it's going to
happen I can't predict that so then that
same intelligence that's giving me life
according to the quantum model of
reality is the same intelligence that's
creating supernovas and causing flowers
to bloom it's it's within us and all
around us it's it's a very wave of
quantum physics I can't control that I
can't expect how the particle is going
to appear or when it's going to appear
but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions and we
believe we we even speculate that it's
possible and someone has to step out
into out of their present beliefs to see
if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
super normal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up
where they can begin the application of
that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation
and I can tell you that you and I are at
our absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment
that the brain gets so organized and so
coherent in front of the brain is
talking to the back of the brain the
right side of the brain is talking on
the left side of the brain there's this
synchronization this psychic Union going
on a flow and the person has tears of
joy rolling down their face that Gestalt
moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that
it's happening to them and the inner
event that's happening to them is more
real than any past event and that's the
moment I know their belief is changing
when we become the living example of
Truth when we actually embody this
that there are no limits to what we can
do and I'm hopeful with human beings
that um that we have this capacity and
and of course when we believe in
ourselves we believe in possibility and
when we leave in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and I think that is
the ultimate belief
feelings
bushings are the end product of past
experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're Gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain and it causes jungles of neurons
to organize themselves into Networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way every
single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and of those feelings and emotions Drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity all of
those emotions are created from past
experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body to memorize that
emotional state better than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then spend the
majority of their life talking about why
they never arrive at their vision of the
future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss you remember
your wedding you remember the birth of
your children you remember catching a
fish off the coast of manzanillo with
your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went to the Casita and you
cooked the mahimahi and you drank
sauvignon blanc and the wind was blowing
off the Sea and the sun was setting and
you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the Past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say I am this way because of
this experience that happened to me 15
years ago
I am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective it
means I haven't been able to change in
the last 15 or 30 years
and Scientific American
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent of what you talk
about in your past isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts in a
matter of seconds you are going to feel
insecure
the moment you feel insecure your brain
is monitoring how you're feeling and you
think more insecure thoughts which then
makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says I am insecure
and whenever you say I am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis trauma disease
diagnosis loss something has to go wrong
in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they're looking at themselves
Through The Eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration memory is
creative that in fact fifty percent of
that story you embellish people make up
that story let me tell you why they make
up that story because they excuse
themselves for the fact that they
haven't been able to change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
it's less of the truth because you got
to work yourself up into a state there
were lions and tigers and they were
right you know they were helicopters
snowstorms didn't matter he was firing
bullets the worst thing you could
possibly imagine and then you've got to
feel that emotion right and then you
look at this oh yeah it must have been
really bad now that's that's your
identity now that's your identity if
your brain is a record of the past
and you were living by the same emotions
that have defined you for the last 10
years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals Drive the same thoughts
then your body as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion
and an emotion that you're creating by
thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week
365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past
and you can create a new future holding
on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what I'm
talking about
so then you
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker or some relative or somebody
in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you are
altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
that's called a mood
a
Anita
what's wrong with you
oh I'm in a mood
really
why are you in a mood
well this thing happened to me four days
ago
and I'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey why is she so angry I don't know why
are you so angry why are you so bitter
why are you so enchilada
[Music]
because I had this experience
seven months ago
and I'm memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end that's
called a personality trait
and people where their emotions on their
sleeve and that's who they think they
are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
Mexico City
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up living from the old
Hardware of the past and the old
emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes all of
a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological Network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain causing
you to think equal to everything that
you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as you're thinking equal to
your environment you keep creating the
same life
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment to think greater than
the circumstances in your life to think
greater than the conditions in your
world in every great person in history
knew this
whether it was Mahatma Gandhi Martin
Luther King the Wright brothers Joan of
Arc
they all had a vision I always say to
people
when is the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and Afraid and
protected it takes practice to do that
and and so we we work with people in
letting them we give them numerous
opportunities the practices over and
over and over again and sooner or later
pedal by pedal it starts to bloom and
all of a sudden there's an authentic
smile on their face and once energy
meets the heart it goes right to the
brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram and an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain but we measure the heart along
with it and when the heart starts
beating coherently in a sense of order
like a like taking a big sheet Jay and
going like that the heart sends a wave
right up to the brain
and the Brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and there's the stroke volume of the
heart in order and then you see these
two or three seconds of beautiful
coherent Alpha the brain is in it's it's
in that creative state then there's a
pause and it happens again and yeah it's
it's it's Beauty it's a it's a symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world but
there's no carrier wave I mean and
people when they make energy reach their
heart there's an external field that's
created it's it's magnetic it's it's
it's measurable and that energy is
frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering cannot
carry the thought of health or wealth
it's not consistent with it it carries a
different set of thoughts
so then
the training then is getting people into
those hard States because once they
start trading that fear or that pain or
that frustration or trying or whatever
forcing you know control for gratitude
and they just let all that go and I say
to them listen if you can't feel
gratitude if you can't feel love I just
want to know what you've been practicing
feeling every day because that feeling
that you're practicing is what you're
always feeling now let's practice
feeling something else in the beginning
it's not going to be easy but you got to
keep following the formula keep doing it
keep doing it keep doing it well
when they start feeling gratitude it's
very interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you something favorable is
happening to you right so you've just
received something or you're receiving
something you say Thank you so gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different Destiny
you could say I'm healthy I'm healthy
I'm healthy I'm wealthy I'm wealthy I'm
wealthy I'm wealthy I'm free I'm free
I'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem it never makes it to the body
because the body is on a different
program
so then when the person starts trading
that and they start opening their heart
well their immune system gets stronger
by 50 percent 50 percent in three days
they start making immunoglobulins their
body's natural defense against viruses
and bacterias 50 percent not a little
bit a lot that's that's one study and SO
trading that telling the body it's in
the in the environment where it already
happened and so that's when the Miracles
start happening that's when people say
I'm not doing anything well of course
you're not you don't have to can you
believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
the latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind does not know the
difference between that external event
and what you're creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to Signal new genes in new
ways to change your body to look like
the event has already occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence in your
brain and body to look like the event
has already occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
now most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
a reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought was a possibility in
the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience the moment you
started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40 percent of your entire brain it
is the creative Center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said what would it be
like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
Vision come true
the moment you ask that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
Center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the CEO it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what if
question it begins to select these
different networks and begins to
seamlessly piece them together and
making your brain fire in new sequences
and in new patterns and new combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action mind
is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that they're thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in Theos filled
with God
they become passionate they started to
open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again that proves
then the person now is changing
fundamentally changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future we have such compelling evidence
in science with brain scans you make
your brain work better you can make your
heart work better you can make your
immune system work better you can make
your cells go from really sick to really
healthy we've got great evidence you can
become immune to Serious viruses you can
be immune in the bacteria we've got the
measurements you can lengthen your life
we have great evidence and people aren't
monks they're not they're not nuns
they're not religious Scholars they're
just common people and then we have
testimony
people who are the example of Truth they
are they are the example of truth I
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody else they
know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what I think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost in emotional
agreement and so people who want to feel
fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and and I think I think there's a door I
just I just think that we have to trust
the innate information that that comes
from within us if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation isn't something that
causes people to feel bad or unworthy it
causes them to open their hearts
it causes them to feel Joy to feel
gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then create that
elevated emotion and you teach people
more information they will continue to
transform themselves and that's called
Evolution if you think the same thoughts
the same thoughts always lead to the
same choices the same choices lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but new thoughts should lead to new
choices and new choices should lead to
new Behaviors new behaviors should
create new experiences and new
experiences should create new emotions
and that should Inspire evolution
we say that your personality creates
your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
we could say that your personality is
your state of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work you literally have
to become someone else
so crossing the river of change going
from the old self to the new South
requires you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
[Music]
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's mind and body and opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs they begin to
create very powerful things in their
life what do you believe is the purpose
of life overall to figure out the
purpose of life okay I know I mean I
mean I I really think it's I think the
mathematics that I've looked at says
there's infinite experiences to have you
will never know the end so then
if you study any religion I mean I've
looked at a lot of them this concept of
Eternity that the soul is going to be
around for eternity
that's a long time and that means you
got to be okay with you for a very long
time yeah so
I think it's I think it's the creation
of more experiences and I think to to I
think we came from Source from
Singularity from Oneness
and we have descended down into density
a fooled by our Senses Into separation
and every single being has a spark of
Oneness of the divine within them and we
got so separate that we now have our own
free will to answer the question is
there more because if you're Oneness it
gets kind of boring after a while like
is there anything else well moment you
ask if there's anything else you're no
longer Oneness you're something other
than Oneness right and you're a a
different Consciousness separate from
Oneness
so I think then we live life and then
when we can predict the feeling of
everything that can happen in our life
and it gets boring and
we're not impressed by anyone or
anything we ask the same question
is there more and that's when the soul
goes ah right well it's been how many
lifetimes you've been doing this okay
there's an Awakening and the and we ask
that question and then all of a sudden
we start getting information and books
and stuff and meet people and it gets
exciting and and it's the it's it's How
the Universe works and so we climb out
of this and I just think there's so many
incredible experiences that are left in
the unknown uh that we get to have and
and then of course when
and the journey is over and you've
evolved to that point then you take that
wisdom and you say here's what I learned
and it was scary down there boy I tell a
great story and then you hang out there
and you go
is there anything else besides and then
here we go again it just never
Insider how do we brainwash ourselves in
times of stress and anxiety in order to
become more peaceful loving and
successful in the future how do we
brainwash ourselves in a different way
sure well
um
that's what I've spent about my whole
life
and and
um wow I mean the first and most
important thing is that you have to
understand that if 95 of who you are is
a set of unconscious programs then the
first step is lighting a match in a dark
place if you want to become someone else
you got to become aware of who you are
yes that means you got to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
you got to start paying attention to how
you speak got to be conscious you
demystify the word meditation and the
word meditation literally means become
familiar with yeah when you become so
familiar with your thoughts so aware of
your emotions so conscious of your
habits that you wouldn't go unconscious
to them again now you're no longer the
program right so so getting people
disentangled from that program we found
out as a formula and when we teach
people how to do certain things with
their focus and opening their awareness
when we teach them how to create a very
disorderly brain that has been driven by
the hormones of stress into a more
orderly coherent brain and teach them
how to open their focus and practice
that they'll come up against those
thoughts and they'll become so familiar
with them listen to this they won't
believe him anymore when they come up
any longer wow and so when they hear
them in their day they'll be like that's
not going to stop me from my future
so if they're sitting there and they
want to quit just because they're
sitting still
and they're not quitting then they're
developing a will that's greater than
those programs and you're breaking out
of the shell and you keep doing that
you're going to get up and do the work
every day because you did it yesterday
and you're going to want to do more of
that because you're getting out of your
past and it feels better and if you keep
doing that and you keep feeling better
every day the question is why wouldn't
you do it every day because you would
ultimately just feel better and then the
more whole you feel means the more you
are connected to your future imagine if
you felt every single day and this is
what I do work on
if I could stay connected to the
emotions of my future all day long
there's no way I would be looking for
when it would be happening how could I
look for when it would be happening if I
feel like it's happening I wouldn't look
anymore which means I wouldn't be
separate from it and that's when you
start creating the magic right that's
when you're in that zone and that's when
that reaffirms that personality that
you're becoming and now you don't you
know wake up in the morning oh God I got
to create my future now you're you're
gonna jump out of bed excited you're not
going to want that magic to end that's
the right how does the person become the
person they are
and why do they keep their health
condition the same and well most people
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact fact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
so most people wake up in the morning if
you think that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny they
start thinking about their problems and
those problems are just memories that
are etched in their brain that are
connected to certain people and objects
and certain things at certain times and
places and the moment they start
thinking about their problems they're
thinking in the past now because every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them
the moment they start feeling unhappy or
feeling sad now their bodies in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being though
the problem is is that the person thinks
so the problem feels the emotion and
that is a thought and feeling that's a
image and an emotion it's a stimulus in
response and that starts the
conditioning process to get the body
emotionally conditioned into the past
now here's the crazy part about it yes
but a familiar past
emotionally
is producing dramatic effects on the
body because the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is fabricating by thought or
memory alone the body's believing it's
living in the same past experience seven
days a week 365 days a year and the
problem with that is is that the
environment signals the gene sap
genetics and the end product of an
experience and the environment there's
an emotion so the person is keeping the
same gene regulated because the body's
believing it's living in the same
environmental condition so
getting that person to step outside of
that familiar known territory into the
unknown
where there is uncertainty and have them
be comfortable there and begin to think
about how they are going to think if you
have been inexperienced uh if you had
experience of trauma say for example and
it's created the feeling of fear and
your fears that it could happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
Mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now all you need now is some cue in
your outer environment that says it's
unsafe that if there's damage there that
you're you're a victim something's
bigger than you that could have an
effect on you well now that feeling of
fear is going to cause you to think
thoughts equal to it so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just have to have the
thought about that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two Protection Systems you gotta you got
a system that protects you from dangers
in your outer world that's that's the
gas pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight or flight number
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you got to
take care of your body so right so so
now that system can work really well
short term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined whether your anger is valid or
Justified or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch we need the
we need to get into relaxation we need
to get back into balance again and and
when we do then we'll metabolize then
we'll we'll assimilate we'll reproduce
we'll we'll excrete properly
so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says Hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no Homeland
Security so they shut down certain
receptors in the immune system they shut
down function of those lymphocytes those
white blood cells that are your inner
Army of protection and it takes a lot of
energy to fight a virus and a bacteria
but if there's no energy Hey listen it
takes energy to raise the body's
temperature what do you think that comes
from that's part of that branch called
the autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance let's talk
about the Neuroscience of culture
because there is a neuroscience to it
you have a brain that looks just like
the person sitting next to you
and if I was to screw off the top of
your heads
and take out your brain and your
partner's brain someone sitting next to
you and I went like this
and I set them out you probably wouldn't
be able to tell them apart
because you share the same structure in
your brain and we call that Universal
traits we call it gross anatomy now
because you share the same brain as the
person sitting next to you you smile
when you're happy you frown when you're
sad you sleep at night wow this is
Mexico you sleep kind of late at night
and get up kind of late in the morning
come on I'm kidding
and you know you grab a stick the same
way we speak a language and because we
share the same gross anatomy of the
brain we have very Universal traits that
we have in common how many people are
with me
but now
how your brain is wired is your
individuality and that's the minute
architecture or the minute structure of
the brain
so then
your brain is wired different than the
person next to you because you have
different experiences but if you share
the same experiences because you're in a
relationship then you have similar
brains that are kind of relating and
relationships are built on common
experiences if we share the same
experiences we share the same emotions
and if we share the same emotions we can
relate with each other
so then think about it like this
you have a hand
and because you have a hand you you have
the same hand as the person next to you
there's only a certain amount of things
you can do with your hand
but now
what makes you unique is your
fingerprint that gives you your
individuality and that is really the
minute anatomy of something related to a
hand are you with me
so now what is the division that unifies
both the universal traits and our
individual traits
and the answer is culture
culture
and culture is defined by the
environment in which you live
the environment in which you work the
environment of your family
an environment is made up of just a few
things are you ready people
objects things places time pets and
that's pretty much your environment so
the culture of Mexico City
is defined by the environment
you eat certain foods you like certain
music you relate with one another
because of the environment in which you
live in
and that culture is Created from the
environment which is different than the
culture of Mongolia
because it's a different environment and
they have different Traditions they have
different Customs because they've had to
survive in a different environment and
so what unifies individual individual
traits and Universal traits is called
culture now think about this
most cultures are defined by the Customs
they have the Traditions the language
their survival skills their habits their
attitudes their beliefs their history
their Arts their social structures that
have unified them as an individual
culture
are you still with me so the people you
work with the people you relate with the
people you interact with you share a
similar culture that bonds you both as
an individual and as a species called
human beings
and Mexicans are different than
Australians because they live in a
different environment and they have
different Traditions you're still with
me but we could say then that culture
typically is defined by things that have
worked in the past
so then
most cultures then
have a choice
to create a new culture means then you
have to Define your culture as a vision
of the future
but most people their cultures are based
on the past present reality what does
that mean we are in a changing world
and the world is changing faster than
most people can keep up
and if you are going to stay defined by
a memory of the past you will not keep
up with this culture because we are
creating a global culture
so then
what defines the vision of the future to
change a culture
and the answer is a very clear intention
a clear purpose combined with an
elevated emotion
and when you combine a clear intention
like a vision of the future
along with an elevated emotion of
inspiration and joy you will create an
empowered individual if someone is so
disconnected to their future their
greater future self if they're so
negative thoughts Suicidal Thoughts
often
hurting themselves potentially often
what can they start to do to just give
some a little bit of relief and peace in
their heart yeah it's simple knowledge
experience wisdom
philosophy initiate that philosophy
Master it yep Mind Body Soul thinking
doing being learning with your head
applying it with your hands knowing it
by heart and this is the Journey of
knowledge because when you learn that
information and you really study it you
are going to begin to see the world
differently because your brain is
changing then when you start saying how
can I use this how can I apply it how
can I personalize it how can I do
something initiate this information what
do I got to do how do I get my behaviors
to match my intentions now this is the
act of trial and error it's so important
you don't make it the first time you
don't give up you get up and you try to
walk again
and you start learning how to do this
and so as you begin to do it over and
over again you start having new
experiences yes wow new experiences
enrich the circuits in your brain
philosophically and now the brain makes
a chemical and now you're feeling more
unlimited you're feeling more whole
you're teaching your body chemically to
understand what your mind intellectually
understood and now you are literally
literally starting to embody that
knowledge yeah it's becoming it's
signaling new Jesus it's new information
but but you can't do it one day and
expect your wealth to come you gotta do
it over and over again yeah so the
repetition of practicing over and over
again
neurochemically conditions the mind and
body begin to work as one you've done it
so many times the body now knows how to
do it subconsciously just like it just
like I knew how to subconsciously lean
into trauma on victim mode right decades
now the body's getting new information
it's going to adapt and and now you're
going to literally become that knowledge
you're going to be coming that's what
you're going to become and so now that's
when you no longer have to try it's who
you are it's yes yeah you've memorized
an internal order that's greater than
anything in your outer world that's
going to tell you something else and I
got run over by a truck and and I broke
64 to bring my spine and I had to make a
decision at that time in my life um
because the diagnosis wasn't very good
and neither was the prognosis and decide
if I was going to spend the rest of my
life on addictive medications and both
surgical rods in my spine or if I was
going to see if the mind could actually
heal the body and so that was my wake-up
call in 1986 and so so I just
um I was at the point where I just had
to make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that I learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so I was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then I thought God
yeah if it worked on me as it worked on
other people so I started looking into
people that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis and their
condition was staying the same getting
worse and all of a sudden it got better
and and I just wanted to look at what
the cause was that was producing that
effect and so
I interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process and one of the most
fundamental elements that they all had
in common with there were a lot of
things that had to do with their mind
and uh and some people had specific
diets in specific regimes some people
use certain
um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how they were thinking on a daily
basis how they were acting on a regular
basis and looking at how they feel uh on
a moment-to-moment basis and and how you
think and how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
has a very direct relationship with your
personal reality which means if you want
to change your personal reality if you
want to change something about your life
you got to change and so the process of
change then becomes the fundamental
process of going from some person that's
familiar and known to you and stepping
out and beginning to make different
choices and to begin thinking different
thinking differently and be into behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and and if you start
thinking acting and feeling differently
our research shows without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality and
not in the new personality and then you
ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition uh it's in
the old person I'm not that person any
longer I was looking uh closely and
there are people
that do this work do do this
transformation work in the meditations
that we teach and they're so impatient
and they're so entitled
and they want an instantaneous change
from the lack of their feelings right
that they never overcome themselves in
their meditation they never overcome
themselves in the meditation and when
they finish their meditation they
believe in this work less
then there are people who say I can tell
you the moment I made up my mind to
change because I had reached the end and
I made a decision and that decision to
change carried an amplitude of energy
that was greater than the hardwired
programs in my brain and the emotional
conditioning in my body and my body
literally responded to my mind in that
moment that the choice that I made
became a moment in time I would never
forget and they'll tell you and that's
the moment I remembered when I was going
to change now
those people then when they sit down to
do the work they're the chemotherapy
hasn't worked
uh the injections didn't work uh the
radiation didn't work uh the surgery
didn't work the diet didn't work the
yoga didn't work this is this is now
their end they have nothing else to
believe in but themselves and they go
all in not 50 not 60 they're going all
in they have nothing else to believe in
now listen
when they go a little bit outside the
known they've got they went a little
further than where they normally would
stop they push themselves to that next
limit
they started believing in themselves
that they could do it a little bit more
they they finished the meditation and
they get up and believing it's it's it's
working more than working less that
they're the person that's believing in
themselves that's why because it's not
the work it's your belief in yourself
right it's and then when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
When You Believe in possibilities you
got to believe in yourself who wasn't
going to believe it
love inspires us it inspires us to give
it inspires us to express it inspires us
to serve
to care for one another to be kind to
one another uh to listen with compassion
and understanding and love actually
causes us to create we become creative
in that state
and you've heard me say that when there
is a change in energy there's a change
in your life and and inspiration is a
change in energy
and if you don't change your energy if
you stay in the same energy then it
makes sense that your life stays the
same
so if you can become inspired and raise
your energy you become aware of things
that you were once unaware of why
because
energy causes us to become conscious of
things we're a once unconscious to in
other words you change your frequency
you have more access to information and
that's the name of the game here so
if you stay at the same level of energy
every single day then you will be
unaware of possibilities so you'll
you'll not be able to create anything
new
so you can't see any possibilities again
from the same energy in order for you to
become inspired by love inspired by
energy you'll become conscious of
possibilities that you were once
unconscious of
now
energy or energy in motion uh their
emotions and so if we live by the same
emotions every single day and we haven't
changed Who We Are
and there's a movement happening or
you're in the creative state
and you stay in the same feelings in the
same familiar emotions then you can't
see any possibilities because you're
looking through the lens of some past
experience and you can only see the same
so then
inspiration then the word inspiration
means
the movement of energy
inspiration to inspire in spirit it is
becoming more energy and less matter
what a few things we can do to support
our inner environment on a daily basis
ah well listen
um the first thing and the most
important thing for me is knowledge and
information
knowledge is really power and and
knowledge and information about yourself
shouldn't it should Empower you it
should empower the self right so when we
learn about the immune system and all
that can do and when you say oh my God
you mean not every virus
gets to me in fact no and the more you
the more you understand that and the
more you coax your immune system into
love and into into like we well I just
did this little thing on um on our
social media where I was talking about
the inner Army of order what would be
the signal you would want that inner
Army to get and so we created this
meditation and we said what would
invincibility feel like signal your body
and feel Invincible how would you feel
if you had an uncompromising will that
you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like because it is that emotion of
invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising will to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for Wow get ready
because you're going to start creating a
Cadence and a rhythm where your your
body's going whoa what what are the what
is all these new chemicals what are all
these new signals right hey it's time
hey uh now all of a sudden receptor
sites on the T cells go wow we got some
new signals coming from the boss here
let's open up all those T-cell receptors
let's go in fact we're we're we would
love a little fight right now because we
got a lot of time on our hands and we
got all our receptors turned on oh
that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear and
frustration and resentment and suffering
uh for an elevated emotion and truly
open your heart again and practice doing
that um
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because I mean all healings happen in
the heart because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to learn how to manifest 10
times faster check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you wanted to create a new
personal reality a new life you'd have
to change your personality which means
you'd have to start thinking about what
you've been thinking about and change it
you'd have to become aware of your
unconscious habits